Powerful freaks of the world teach you that low energy,
not unlike Brian's normal.
Do you know why folks?
Because he's got the super aids seepa deluxe.
So Brian has to go to the doctor today.
I'm forcing them to go to the doctor.
Police,
oops,
do shit though.
Every time I go there,
they say,
well,
they look at all your,
your aides in all your aides cancels each other out.
It's like
battling Brian Redman.
All your diseases are duking it out in your system.
You just,
I don't know,
man.
I,
you can't,
uh,
you can't be sick for four or five days in a row without at least getting looked
at because you might have something,
they can go,
oh,
you have this.
Here's that.
You know,
it's the non eating thing that's really starting to get me.
Yeah,
that's not good,
dude.
You could have a parasite.
You could have something,
you know,
you might've eaten something.
It's very possible.
It doesn't catch you smell a certain strain of marijuana that makes you hungry
and less nauseous.
And I tried to smoke weed last night and just made me
puke.
Wow.
Uh,
well,
uh,
that's not good.
That's not a good ad for that and that sucks.
And then has nothing to do with squarespace.com which is our fucking sponsor,
squarespace.com if anybody's ever used it
to make a a website where you can look through your Webcam and take a look at
Brian and find out what's wrong with them instantly
that's coming,
right?
That kind of technology that's going to be available.
They're going to be able to look at you and go,
Oh dog,
we see what's up.
I'm going to take a photo of you like real close up of your retina or some shit
and then in the future those people look in there and go up.
Doug's got an issue with is
bladder.
I was looking for a body part.
It wasn't too dangerous.
The eyes,
this is the key key to the bladder.
Why not?
They can move to the bladder?
She goes,
I know that they can make bladders now they've found a way to make bladders like
in a test tube
connect.
If you have problems with your liver,
is that replaceable?
They can.
They can certainly transplant livers,
they even,
um,
but you can also transplant a piece of your liver livers,
a weird livers like,
uh,
they regenerate.
So if like a liver breaks open,
I'll give you get an up dangerous a car accident or something like that.
Sometimes you can have like serious liver damage,
but even if you lose a piece of your liver,
your liver can regenerate.
So the idea is you can transplant like a part of someone's liver,
you can help them by giving them a piece of your liver and then that can sort
of,
uh,
you know,
jumpstart their little system and then their liver,
I guess,
I don't know if it grows or what.
I need to find that out before I start talking about it.
I don't know if it grows,
but I know that a,
you can donate a piece of your liver.
You should make a website on Squarespace.
That tea for people that went and donate livers Oregons or the whole idea of
donating organs is wow.
Which is we're fucking swapping the tax deductible when you donate an Oregon
anyway,
go make a website.
Fuck
squarespace.com it's a great slogan for them.
Cool.
Make a website.
Fucks me.
And Doug actually hung out with these Squarespace people all weekend.
Yeah,
we red square spacers.
Yeah.
My a food podcast.
They gave out free,
uh,
what do you call it?
A bloody Mary's to everybody because it was a breakfast edition.
Oh,
that's bad on Squarespace.
But bloody Mary's for everybody.
But then later that night at the bar,
there's a girl from Squarespace.
It was just like anyone standing at this bar.
We're buying drinks,
shifts,
spaces gangster.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it was great.
I wouldn't do that though.
What,
what if,
you know,
if you're buying people drinks,
they tend to get fucked up and then they tend to do stupid shit when they're
fucked up.
But then you get in trouble for it.
It was,
you know,
very last call adjacent when this went down in a hotel bar.
You know,
hotel bars like to close at weird times,
like two hours before they could be,
they could have been made made $200,
you know,
$200 more than 200 you know,
two hours worth of selling booze to a bunch of nerds at a podcast festival.
And they're like,
no,
we got to shut it down.
So it was last call.
So like she only had to buy like two rounds.
Oh,
well we didn't go crazy on it,
but it was still,
thank you Squarespace.
Very generous.
Yeah.
And it's a cool company that's does things like that.
It's also a gangster move.
They're buying drugs.
I mean,
that's what they did.
Who wants to get fucked up?
That's what they did.
They just said,
who wants to get fucked up?
No one's drinking and not get fucked up.
I got news for you.
There's a lot of liars out there pretending.
Well,
I just,
you know,
I enjoy a drink.
You enjoy getting fucked up.
Okay.
I'm not saying you're getting all the way fucked up,
but if you have a drink,
you're getting a little fucked up.
All right.
You're starting to get fucked up.
Squarespace is getting people fucked up.
It was great being on that asked episode where they were one of your sponsors.
Hey,
they're nice people if they choose to let us go because we're telling the truth.
How dare you?
How dare he?
How dare this place.
We wouldn't
do that.
Um,
what it,
what it is.
So we'll just get to this.
Um,
if you're,
if you're listening to us going,
what the fuck is Squarespace?
Jesus Christ shouldn't say Jesus Christ like that.
People get mad.
Santa Claus,
same guy.
Golly,
Santa Claus,
um,
square and they're funny.
They're the same to me folks.
Um,
Squarespace is a way to build an awesome website online with their website.
You can use their website to make websites super easy to do and you don't even
have to enter in your credit card information when you're trying out their
service.
And they have,
you know,
over 20 bad ass designs works on everything.
IPODS,
androids,
fucking Linux.
If you're one of those Weirdos,
when those gangster hacker,
hacker type characters,
I'm basic.
I only use unix based
Squarespace.
We'll work on that shit too.
Um,
and uh,
you can set up an online store.
Super easy to do.
Brian is probably built 20 websites since they've been our sponsor,
like,
and he's built every single one of them during the time that it takes us to do
this commercial.
It's really that easy.
I mean,
it's fucking ridiculous.
And like I said,
you can try it out before you actually enter in your credit card information.
You can make your own website and then you let you know this was pretty fucking
bad ass.
Boom.
You given me credit card information.
And then,
uh,
if you use the code Joe and the number 10,
you will get 10% off your first purchases on new accounts and including monthly
and annual plans.
So that's squarespace.com and use the offer code all in one word,
Joe and the number 10 very cool website,
very cool people and a,
we appreciate them supporting the podcast.
We're also brought to you by what's Today.
Do Masani Lumosity,
not luminosity.
How do you say it?
Luma illuminosity it's too much for Brian.
He's like,
this is too complicated.
Lumosity.
Lou Masi t say that Lumosity you should,
you had benefit from Lumosity?
I probably,
I'm not saying Lumosity makes you smarter because apparently no one can ever
prove that something makes you smarter.
I would,
I would imagine that your brain,
uh,
fires better.
Let's say that when you were,
you're exercising it on a regular basis and so Lumosity is set up to be sort of
like a gym for your brain.
It's really pretty bad ass.
Um,
I've,
I've heard about stuff like this for a long time.
Like Chris Mcguire actually set me hip to this kind of shit way back in the day.
He used to have a video game that he would play.
It's like some Nintendo game and it was a game that was just designed,
I don't know if it was Nintendo,
it was a game that was just designed to like give you like a little mental
problems to solve.
And he was like,
it's really good to do,
especially as you get older and you're not going to school anymore and you're
not really reading that much and not really exercising your mind,
your mind.
Like you'd be amazed at how the mind gets used to certain tasks.
And if you give it like exercise,
you can actually like speed up the results of some of these things that you're
a,
you're trying to improve your memory or your attention and they actually have
these games that are set up.
They're very measurable.
It's really kind of interesting because,
um,
you can sort of design a program and a,
there's a bunch of flexibility to it depending on what you're trying to do.
Like it can be very job specific.
Like if you have something,
you know,
a,
you at work,
we feel like you're,
you're not as effective multitasking they have,
they have games and improve your ability to think in a multitasking way.
It's really weird shit.
It's kind of fucking cool.
Um,
I thought that someone should have come up with something like this a long time
ago.
Um,
I thought,
uh,
when I,
when I saw Chris Mcguire's video game,
I just assumed that there were some websites like this out there.
But until Lumosity came along,
I never heard of a,
um,
a really popular one.
I think angry birds makes you smarter.
It tells it.
What about that candy game that everybody plays?
What's the candy game?
There's some new candy
crush,
candy crush.
Everybody plays that right?
I see people freaking out about that game and then you have to like keep,
keep sending them money.
It keeps getting more and more complex.
Those games are genius fan.
They figured out a way to get people hooked on this game and then once people
get hooked because then you have to pay money to get to certain levels and then
what's,
what's the,
got you,
they got you.
You know,
but hey,
you know,
they're designing these fucking things.
Not saying there's anything wrong with that.
If people are enjoying it then that's a lot.
If it's crack,
I mean it's good entertainment depending on how much money,
how much money do you think it could possibly cost to be completely addicted to
an iPad game?
A lot better.
Could real up 100 bucks a month.
Maybe that much,
but why should that be illegal?
But gambling is legal.
Come on in folks.
Come on.
Most things I,
most apps I buy if I,
I haven't bought many,
but when you buy him,
they're like five bucks or something and that it's a onetime fee.
Right.
But I guess I'm not,
you know,
I'm not messing around with no angry
birds.
Yeah.
There's some games though that will fuck you.
This of games.
Do they keep,
they keep fucking pulling that money out.
You just,
you get deeper and deeper into it and you go crazy.
I'm on this site,
it's called Hollywood poker where I played poker
and the idea is you can go there and you could play with a pseudo celebrities
like me and uh,
they charged the people that play,
but for me it's free.
So I just sit around and playing it a lot.
Cause I,
I like playing poker and uh,
oh and people can play with you.
You play as Doug Benson?
Yeah.
That's what it was like a picture of me.
And then they just had a alive,
alive tournament to raise money for a few different charities.
And uh,
I got to play briefly with Bruce.
Buffer was there
and uh,
I didn't drop your name cause I'm sure every guy that goes up to him goes to
Rogan.
But,
um,
he,
he seemed very nice,
very nice guy.
Came in a ninth overall in the tournament.
I came in eighth.
Yeah,
he's a really good poker player.
Bruce loves poker.
He's a,
I know he's played in the world series of poker and they gave him a microphone
when it started and he did the whole,
you know,
thing.
He's self guys solid.
He's a pro.
He's a real pro.
He's a,
he's such a character.
I love that guy.
He's a sweetheart though.
Cause we were just casually,
that is weird.
Right?
He's always in these impeccable suits.
This big diamond rings and Shit.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's a really cool guy too.
And uh,
you know,
he's been with the UFC longer even than me.
He uh,
he was involved,
I'm pretty sure he did the um,
the broadcasting,
like the one that I went to,
the first one I ever went to,
which was like UFC 12,
I'm pretty sure he was the announcer.
I'm pretty sure if it wasn't him.
He definitely did some in that era and then he's been pretty much,
he's the one a day.
What a crazy gig.
Tony's got a really funny joke about him.
That's family just wrote that reason.
It's really funny,
but I don't want to give it up.
I'll just say Tony has an awesome John.
I hate what?
Hate that I heard about this joke.
Go to a comedy club.
Someone already knows what the joke is.
That's so gross.
Um,
they asked,
they yell out for it.
Those sons of bitches.
Well,
that's not that bad.
It's not as bad.
Certainly as as,
uh,
heard yelling out,
heard it on the book.
Anyway,
um,
like I said,
a Lumosity,
um,
is sponsoring the podcast and it's a very interesting website.
And then I started using it.
I like it.
It's fun.
It's a bunch of games,
a bunch of interesting games and I don't feel as much like I'm just an idiot
sitting in front of the computer playing games.
I feel like I'm actually making my mind more flexible by harnessing the brain's
natural ability to adapt to new stimuli.
I think it's based on,
uh,
I think they call it neuroplasticity.
You know what?
I just handed the background.
I hear some non neural plasticity,
but I'm saying I hear him all the fuck.
I was doing some shit to his dome.
Doug's smokes more than Joey Diaz.
Yeah,
probably lumosity.com.
Tell them that you heard it from me,
Joe Rogan.
Each session only takes a few minutes.
You can do it from work at home.
There's from,
you can do it from an iPad and iPhone.
They have Lumosity apps.
So I'm go and a and check it out.
Lou Masa,
t,
l,U ,
m o s,
I t y.com.
Click on the start training button to create your own program.
Then start playing your first game.
That's lumosity.com and tell them that you heard it from me,
Joe Rogan.
So go check that shit out.
Um,
and we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com got a new flavor of a hemp
force protein that's in.
Now we have a,
a vanilla asai protein powder.
It's a delicious,
it's so yummy.
Super good for you too.
And now apparently they're going to allow,
uh,
the growing of hemp in California for industrial use.
Yes.
Yeah.
So if this,
if this actually goes through and the federal government doesn't come in and
arrest farmers for growing an awesome plant,
if that happens,
then we'll be able to invest in a farmers in California and a,
and help the economy.
And I mean,
it sounds like a horse shit.
Like,
you know,
that sounds like promotion horse shit.
But I would love if on it was enhancing the economy by allowing people to make a
living in 2013 by selling a very beneficial plant.
If we could do that,
I think that would be pretty fucking awesome.
It's not about getting high either.
It doesn't even get you high.
It's about the,
the,
the protein you get from it,
the amino acids you get from it,
the fact that you can use the fiber makes amazing cloth and amazing paper.
It's super fucking stupid that in 2013,
that shit's still illegal.
So we're really hoping that this works out and goes through.
We're not going to do anything illegal.
We get all of our hemp from Canada,
it's legal to grow and legal to sell in Canada.
It's legal for us to buy it.
So we buy it from them.
It's so crazy.
It's so dumb that it's a totally legal product,
but it's illegal to grow in America.
It's a,
that's a fucking disgrace.
It's a disgrace to farming.
It's a disgrace to the whole idea of agriculture.
It's a disgrace.
It is one of the most beneficial plants known to human beings and assholes have
made it illegal.
It's racist.
Craziness.
I mean that's the initial,
yeah.
The initial stories were all based on racism.
It's so stupid.
Uh,
but we're hoping either way we buy it from Canada and uh,
we,
we get the best shit we can possibly get.
That's the whole idea behind on it on it is like what we call a human
optimization website.
We're just trying to sell you cool shit that's really good for you.
Cool Shit that I use.
Cool Shit that Aubrey uses.
Cool,
cool shit that MMA fighters use for strength and conditioning equipment like
kettle bells and battle ropes and steel maces and steel clubs.
And all these different things that uh,
that benefit functional strength.
And of course we also sell a primal bells,
which are these kettle bells that have uh,
these uh,
awesome fucking sculptures of a chimpanzees,
orangutans and gorillas.
And we have a,
a smaller one coming out too.
It's going to be a,
I think it's a different champ and 25 pounds or it might be a monkey.
I'm going to be a monkey.
No more battle ropes,
battle ropes were right there son.
Right in the middle of the day.
The snakes in your face,
I can get,
get,
go to the doctor signed there was in Santa Monica,
there's like this,
that park where everyone works out in and tons of people will have these battle
ropes.
It's a great workout man.
Even saying how tiring it is.
Yeah.
You can get a really good work on like you know,
you,
you do like these 32nd bursts,
like 32nd sprints and then put it down for 30 seconds.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many different things you could do with it could jump up in the air
and whip it.
You throw them side to side,
throw him up and down.
Super awesome conditioning stuff and it's really good for your arms.
Like one of the best things that condition your arms,
like if you're in into functional strength and movement because it's such an
awkward thing to whip a rope around,
you know,
requires so many different muscles to get engaged,
but we believe in all that kind of shit.
Different strengthen conditioning equipment that uses the entire body.
That's the concept behind it that,
you know,
isolation exercises are good to look sexy if you want to have some nice 10
tanks,
you know,
do a lot of bench pressing and bench press isn't really isolation as my as well.
There's a lot of things engaged like,
but like curls,
like you see guys doing preacher curls to build their bicep up.
That's such a stupid move that doesn't exist in nature.
Like when would you rather have your arms straighten out and you're,
you're pulling your bicep up like that.
That's so dumb.
It says it's just some gyms and walk around in school.
Some guys,
they're only designed to look sexy.
It's like you're designed to do this weird isolated move and it will do that,
but then you're going to have this weird imbalanced body and the way you're
really supposed to lift weights.
If you want your body to perform at its optimum,
your whole body should be using e be moving as an individual unit.
That's when you get real what they call functional strength.
That's where like strong man exercises come from,
but when you see people doing dead lifts,
you see people doing squats,
you see people doing cleans and presses.
All that stuff is full body movement and those full body movements and engage
everything.
Those are the ones that really make you physically strong and and applicable
ways like,
like in sports and,
and you know if you,
if you enjoy doing something you can benefit tremendously from a good strong
strength and conditioning program in your life.
Get into it slowly,
try it out.
It's fucking great.
You can get your body into a really good physical state.
If you're a healthy person and you don't have any medical limitations,
you can get your body feeling much better than it is right now.
As Doug Benson fires up,
again,
look on my trying to,
I'm not trying to pressure you into getting healthy Fox,
but oh,
in nit use a code name,
Rogan,
and you will save 10% off any and all supplements including Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
new mood,
all that good shit.
All right folks,
Doug Benson is here.
So you use the code name,
Rogan save 10% you're not a health pusher for sure.
I am.
But I've been at,
I've been at meals with you.
Yeah.
And you don't even tell anybody what to eat.
And you always Passover a,
another big plate of something that's awful for people like you love.
You still love food.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
eating late at night.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a bad thing at night.
It's a bad thing.
It's a bad thing if you're overweight.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it can definitely put weight on you,
but I'm not overweight.
No,
I know you can get away with it,
but it's only,
I only get away with it cause I know you're enabling fats like me that get to go
with you and have these delicious meals.
Propose show food is probably one of the most pleasurable things ever,
isn't it?
Oh it's,
food is the most pleasurable thing,
but food for us to like after a big show.
Like it's like when after a big show that goes well,
you have a great feeling.
It's a great feeling of relief.
There's a great feeling of like you had a great exchange with these people.
They had a good time.
It feels like super positive all around.
It's what makes you work hard to do standup and it really get good at it.
And then you're not going to just go sit by herself or go to sleep or something.
Yeah.
You got to go out.
And we definitely,
the posts show meals are like the most fun meals.
You know,
we're all relaxed.
We did our show and then we can go to some groovy place like fucking Chinese
restaurant that we went to me Segura and uh,
Brian Cowen in Toronto.
God Damn,
it was good.
Holy Shit.
You forget.
Like if you're in like a real city like Toronto,
you can get some fucking serious like legit ethnic food.
You know,
where people don't even barely speak English and they're serving Chinese food in
the ducks that are hanging in the window and shit.
One of those joints.
It was fucking good.
Every five out of the road with you and you're like,
I'm just going to take it easy and go home after
the,
you know,
after whatever we just did.
I'm a,
I'm always,
you know,
it's sad cause it's,
cause every time we go out we always do.
You always find some new amazing restaurant and every town everywhere and the
people,
they're always super nice to you.
And it's a,
it's really,
it's good fun.
Yeah.
It's always good fun.
It's good fun.
I love tip in the shit out of waiters.
Hey,
um,
we don't need any music.
Doug Benson said we're going to experience,
yeah,
they were like,
we were going for like 40 minutes week.
Yeah.
There's no need to like,
there's no need to have like play music.
We've already started worthy off and running.
It's on.
Yeah.
And all the shit that's bad for you though.
I think that a post show,
uh,
meals on the short list is a pre shrugged drinks.
There's a lot of things.
Yeah.
Well also that's my problem is I can't have a big meal before a show cause it
just,
it makes me,
I literally do not want to perform,
you know,
which,
which is such a horrible feeling because that's the,
my favorite thing to do is perform.
And so to feel like not getting,
you don't feel like getting up there.
That's,
that sucks.
So it's a terrible feeling.
Yeah.
So you can't,
uh,
you can't really load up on a huge delicious meal before a show.
I stopped eating gluten.
I stopped eating gluten several months ago.
That's pretty interesting.
That's a big thing for,
does it seem real all of a sudden that it's just everywhere.
They're constantly talking about gluten.
Well,
you know why it's because I think a lot of people have just sort of accepted a
certain way of feeling.
They just,
this is just how I feel.
This is my health,
this is my health level.
And then you can do something like,
especially if you are set celiac's disease,
like a lot of people have like real allergies to wheat.
It's like it's a serious issue and we don't send everything.
Yeah,
I don't have an allergy to it,
but I noticed when I stopped eating it like almost right away that my energy
level was way more,
even throughout the day,
like there wasn't this big crash after meals and I started thinking about that.
It's crazy if that's really the case,
that the crash of two meals is always bread or pasta.
And then I stopped and thought about every time that I got like really like
stuffed up on Lasagna or spaghetti or something like that.
That is the worst after food coma.
It's the most delicious shit while you're eating it.
Yeah.
But you fucking pay hard.
Like your body wants to crash because it's processing all that wheat.
It's all I just fucking gummy,
weird pasty shit sitting in the bottom of your stomach that doesn't exist in
nature.
Some weird creation that we've concocted and strength.
It's funny you said gummy because the gum has weed in it.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
All it took was one guy saying to me,
you know all that gum,
you're chewing.
You're just,
you're just triggering yourself to want more wheat.
And I stopped chewing gum altogether and gum have weed in it.
If you've looked at the Google this,
Google it up.
Supposedly a lot of it does.
Wow.
There's gum have
bitch Siri can't eat gluten free gum.
Which brand to choose.
Wow.
Some gum has
fucking gluten in it.
That is nuts.
What are the gluten free one?
We,
it says wheat is chewing gum.
This is incredible.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Back in the days before there was chewing gum and this store is,
farmers actually made their own with grains of wheat.
Well,
that's why you see assholes out in the sticks chewing on the end of the thing of
wheat.
Yeah.
It's like gum.
Wow,
I want more of this week.
Wow.
Yeah.
You put the the Er.
Wow.
You can chew it down to gum.
He put the grains of wheat and your mouth.
You crunch down slowly.
I started chewing.
Your jaw and teeth will turn into a stone grinder and you will immediately
begin,
begin to taste the nutty flavor of the whole wheat.
If you continue to,
and for a few minutes swallowing the SS saliva but not the grains.
There'll be a little mound of dough right inside your mouth.
Keep chewing and it will get smoother and soon turn into old fashioned farmers.
Gum farmers gum is pure wheat gluten.
It has pleasing texture and will last and last and probably no flavor.
Well that's why that shit shouldn't be in your fucking stomach.
Like that's a perfect example.
You're reading that and it it.
I stopped swallowing gum too.
I decided to stop doing that.
Flushing.
Oh,
I'm eating too much gum in my forties I think it's about time it out.
Swallowing gum.
That's hilarious.
So off it because somebody told me like,
oh,
it stays in your stomach for it 10 years or something and it's,
and then I went online.
I was like,
oh,
that's bullshit.
You Shit it out.
But so I just started,
it doesn't seem like the right thing to have down there.
That was one of those myths.
So that went across the world that if you ain't got another system for 10 years
or watermelon seeds,
you grow watermelon inside your belly.
Have you heard that?
That's called pregnancy and it's normal.
Well,
you know,
Anthony Bordain told me that people get that,
um,
that the same stomach disease that Brock Lesnar had,
what is it called?
Um,
where you,
uh,
you have lesions,
diverticulitis that Anthony Bordain so you can get that from seeds.
Like a seed can get stuck inside your body.
It's not,
it does not necessarily entirely from just eating meat the way like Brock Lesnar
supposedly it was like,
because he didn't eat enough fiber.
He's such a fucking carnivores,
just chewing down stakes all day and no vegetables or anything like that.
So he had developed like a backup,
you know,
like he got clogged up down there,
but he said that anything could do it.
Like,
um,
you know,
like seeds can get stuck in there.
That's good.
I forced myself to eat vegetables with every time I have a stake just cause I
somewhere got in my head that like it's just bad to just have a stake.
Even though I,
I could just fuck up a steak and not even mess with the vegetables.
They always get a vegetable that goes good with it and then like put some in
every bite,
you know like I'll throw some spinach on my steak,
you know.
Well they say it's good digestive wise to to s like to open up the pipes.
The idea is like you have a big salad and then the big salad sorta like pushes
the door open for the lumps of stake shit.
But it could come.
It's like the fiber and the,
the,
the watery texture of all that vegetables,
all the water content of that food and makes it easy.
The process,
like if you just eat nothing but salads for a couple of days,
your shit's will be magnificent.
There'll be beautiful,
they just slide out of you.
So storing you just eat salads.
I don't think it's a good idea to do like long term.
I think that you know,
but I think you,
you would be surprised at how much protein is in vegetables.
Like Broccoli apparently has a lot of protein in it.
Like they don't keen wise a lot of protein in it.
You know,
hemp has a tremendous amount of protein in it.
Hemp is very high in protein and has a essentially amino acids like say they
know you can get a lot at eating plants,
but it's way easier to be like optimally healthy if you take in some animal
protein even if it's only eggs.
That's a weird thing with like vegans in such vegans and such.
When my Tom,
what's his name,
the fucking huckleberry Finn and Tom Sawyer,
Mark Twain,
vegans inside,
they only eat eggs.
It's just a thing.
It's really weird cause I guess the idea is that you don't want to have
domesticated animals period.
But it doesn't hurt the animals.
You know they have eggs every day.
It's,
it's really,
it's,
it's super healthy to eat if you don't have to eat the chickens.
The chickens can be free range.
They can have a nice little life.
I mean,
chickens are not like super complicated animals.
They don't really need to be like living in the wild.
And if they lived in the wild,
guess what?
They're not going to last.
Chickens can't even fly.
You know,
someone's going to get them,
whether it's coyotes or they go to sleep at night and they just sit there,
you know?
Do you know what happens when you just sit in there and a coyote comes around
when the coyotes hunt,
they hunt at night.
You know,
I mean the chickens really wouldn't even be around men.
It's a silly idea.
Um,
the idea is that,
you know,
you shouldn't have anything to do with domesticating animals.
I think that must be what they're saying because it doesn't even have to do with
murder.
Eggs are delicious and they come right out of the chicken and nobody's harmed.
Simple and make them every,
every vegetarian Vegan I know is totally on the egg tip.
They eat eggs.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's good.
That's everyone I know.
We can't be a Vegan.
If you're eating eggs that's not vegan
eggs or,
yeah,
yeah.
So there are vegetarians or they go or they say I'm,
I'm,
I'm not a strict Vegan,
but I adopt a lot of the Vegan vegans.
I know like they also go,
oh,
but I do fish.
That's not a Vegan does it?
Silly bitches.
That's an La Vega and that's Tony La being like convenient.
Well we'll,
Tony's very much vegan except for that.
Right.
You know,
he eats animal to know what I'm saying.
I'm saying like most vegans,
I know like Tony,
they all have that one thing though where they're like,
I'm not die hard to the point of everything cause I still eat fish or egg or
something.
So it's more of a health choice,
the ideology.
But Tony's hilarious because he fucking smoked cigarettes and smoke cigarettes
like a little chimney and a,
you know,
and he's like eating Vegan that's going to counteract.
He drinks every night.
Every night I go,
I go to the bar and I'm like,
you know what,
I'm not going to drink tonight.
And then I'm like,
Tony,
you're not drinking that night,
right?
We got,
and he goes,
Oh yeah,
I'm drinking.
He's the one that was put goes,
well,
if he does and I'm going to do it,
you know,
it was fun to do too.
He's a funny dude that's called being a comedian.
We're a mess.
We're,
we're a fucking crazy people.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's why I'll you know,
may never quit drinking is cause I'm in a nightclubs every night and I enjoy it.
Yeah.
It's kind of fun,
unfortunately,
you know,
like it's why take the fun out of what we're doing by like insisting on staying
alive.
But no,
you don't.
Like most comedians,
it turns sober.
They,
uh,
you know,
they,
uh,
they lose a step.
They,
they,
they lose interest in being in the clubs and you know,
and doing standup.
And it's like,
I never want to lose interest in that,
you know,
by the way,
when I said they lose a step,
it doesn't mean you have to,
and I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that they,
but I am saying that a lot of guys who,
uh,
who like that I've known that become sober,
they lose like a certain amount of zest.
They all of a sudden now they're like,
well,
this is just life now.
There's no altering the state of consciousness.
I'm just going to stay mellow and flat and they have other things that fill the
void,
you know,
like,
like Chris Hardwick sober,
but he plays video games all day long.
Every day you have to fill the void.
They got to have something fun.
Yeah.
It's going to be the reason to wake up every day.
To some,
some other addiction.
But I,
I don't think there's anything wrong with being sober and don't get me wrong.
And I think that like Hicks did his best stuff after he was sober.
It's not interesting.
You don't have to be a fucked up to make good comedy.
I mean,
there's no doubt about it.
Oh,
that's true.
For sure.
But,
but,
but to,
you know,
to appreciate the experience,
like once he was sober,
I bet bill Hicks,
like walk in the club do,
is set and walk out of the club.
Like probably,
you know what I mean?
It's no fun to be in there if you can't participate.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
if you can't hang out and joke around and laugh,
that's like one of the most fun things about being a comedian is hanging out
with comedians shooting the shit after shows.
You know,
we'll be going in the morning.
It might be the best.
There is times man walking just all together.
Hilarious times after shows.
Yeah,
that's probably a good look.
Good reality show.
Stand up post show.
It shows over,
get off stage and you know everybody has follow him around from rounds,
the eat and just talk shit after shows.
It's like contrived.
It's Omniac but in packs of comedians and not just David towl actually a great
fucking idea.
It is a good idea.
That's a great idea.
Holy Shit.
Comedians after shows eating for don't be stealing this internet.
God goddammit
Doug,
do you ever have any problems cause you,
you drink a lot.
Do you ever have any tummy troubles or any,
any problems for me to call me trouble you do every time I see you you're
always,
you know with your vodka and drink way too much vodka.
But I,
you know like when people
offer me shots,
like I say no all the time now.
Yeah.
Cause that to me is just like once you've had a few shots then it's just like,
then you just have a lot of shots and then I hate hangovers.
Like that's my thing is that it's like drink as much as I can to get my buzz
going and then not be hung over the next day.
And it's very,
it's a very small window there that you have to aim for.
Right.
So I don't always get there,
but no Tommy troubles or anything call me.
Do you have to go potty?
No,
I don't really.
But I also,
like Joe was saying about how people just sort of like accept how they feel.
I could probably feel a lot better if I stopped drinking,
you know,
four or five VOD cause every night for sure it will definitely help.
Yeah.
But the food thing,
having fun,
you know,
and I'm not,
that's what the scales have to adjust.
Like you,
you with what you have right now.
It sounds like you might change some things in your life if that,
if how you're feeling now would continue if you didn't.
That's just standard.
Brian Talk.
Listen to me.
He's going to ride that boat right into the fucking rocks.
Last time I was sick it was because of drinking I think.
And it was because I used to drink jack and diet cokes every night and then I
went switched it to ginger ale because that's better on your stomach,
but it's her Turkey one on one and it's,
it's worse.
Turkey one at one's worse than Jack.
It's more alcohol.
Oh really?
That's what that went away.
So I couldn't,
I couldn't tell you.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can.
You definitely can't red line your system forever.
That's one thing,
right?
Like it's always good to balance it out.
Like it's one of the things I actually always admired about Andy Dick.
Andy Dick would go on as a mad benders,
but I'd never seen anybody takes more vitamins.
That fucking kid would have trays of vitamins and we bring to work and take one
of these,
one of these,
he would just counteract,
I mean that's to make up for all the partying,
sort of analogous to his life.
He's just,
you know,
he has moments of sobriety where it completely understands,
that this is,
this is who he is and this,
you know,
he's trying to be a nice guy and then he goes off the rails,
craziness.
And then he brings it back.
It's like this huge smoothies.
He had two liter of smoothie.
Well he always did that.
He always ate like super healthy and they always like,
and then he would just go fucking crazy.
But that's just Andy.
But again,
I don't think you'd make a person like Andy unless they're kind of off the rails
like this.
You don't get that guy.
You don't get that.
None.
Like that's,
you know,
you'll back me up on this Joe.
There's probably no funny or actor than him.
So hilarious.
Like so good at like he did it.
A lot of news radio,
like a lot of quick turns and beets in one scene that he plays beautifully.
Like he's almost like a silent film comedian.
Uh,
physicality wise like he can,
it doesn't seem like there isn't anything he could do in that,
in that
area.
As a comic actor,
I think he's probably one of the funniest guys ever.
He really,
there was whole show was full of them.
But yeah,
like as a comic actor on a Sitcom,
he's fucking brilliant and that's why he got away with so much for as long as he
did.
Cause everybody loved him as a person and as a funny character.
We used to do scenes together and I couldn't get through the scene.
I couldn't like I had to stop because I was cracking up.
Like I'm not supposed to be doing anything.
I'm supposed to be like stone faced and he's doing is mad at it and I'm fucking
lying.
I have to like walk away.
We did one scene where like I couldn't stop laughing.
It was so good.
We were all standing out and you know,
everybody's giving me shit about it.
I said,
I was so apologetic,
I was like,
I don't mean to be fucking this up,
but he was killing me.
He was so,
he was asking,
he was talking about all these different things that he ate and ask if he was
going to die.
It was just one ridiculous thing after another in context,
like you'd have to see it like in context,
I'm,
no,
I'm not doing a good job of explaining why it was so funny.
But I was stone cold sober at the time too,
by the way.
I didn't even smoke pot.
So when he's making me cry,
I'm sober crying gland.
Imagine if I used to smoke weed back then and I was hanging out with him.
Well as soon as he said you couldn't stop laughing,
I was gonna say,
oh,
so how often were you high on that shit?
I don't think I got high wa maybe like maybe once or at the most,
twice through.
Not only think I did twice through the entire time we were filming that show and
if I did,
it was always drinking.
Like,
I was drunk at a party and someone says,
Hey,
do you want to,
you want to try a hit of this joint?
I'm like,
Eh,
all right.
Come on.
Hanging out with some comics.
Oh party,
we'll party.
Am I going to party behind the comedy store?
You know,
that's,
it's like,
I think that,
you know,
comedians are weird when it comes to consciousness.
You know,
comedians are weird when it comes to our,
uh,
our,
our want to change our consciousness because so many of us like have like
radical consciousness altering things that we,
we,
we fight with.
Like,
so many comics are hooked on like,
either like some form of drug,
either speed or there's a lot of comics get hooked on coke.
It's classic stories of Boston where all these guys doing blow together.
Like,
I got to get going on it my whole career.
I've never seen another comedian do a line of coke.
Whoa.
Isn't that crazy?
Really?
That's just who I run with.
You know?
That's amazing.
Well,
you know,
I appreciate that about you too,
that you're,
you're really like,
uh,
you,
you've talked about coke like really poorly before.
You know that you'll say like,
why would you fuck with that stuff?
Never even,
I've never tried it.
Yeah,
I haven't either.
Oh,
you guys are missing out.
Try and while we are,
I bet we know.
I would tell you that you should try once,
but I believe that about so many things that I'm not going to get around to
that.
Uh,
but those,
most,
those wouldn't lead
to cause if I did love it,
I'm afraid I would want to do it again.
Yeah,
sure.
Heroin feel,
you know,
shooting heroin probably feels great,
but you know why?
Why take that risk?
You have an addictive personality.
No,
Joe,
I don't,
I mean,
Brian,
as he hits the pipe,
look,
I don't,
I don't think you should fuck with anything that gets,
that really gets in your system like that.
That's my feeling.
I don't trust my system enough.
I,
I'm not a very,
I don't get addicted to substances,
but I've had like serious video games,
addictions and the other addictions in my life for sure.
So when I see something that's like physically addictive too,
not just mentally,
not like gambling,
but like physically addictive,
it gets into your system and you need,
yeah,
I see what it does.
And people seem to be having a certain amount of fun on coke,
but nobody's like from the second they do it to the second the feeling goes away
is just super happy about it the whole time.
No,
it's a,
it's a horrible calm down.
See,
that's why I don't understand why anyone would be addicted to it because when
you're coming down for it from it,
and especially the next morning where you're like,
I spent this much money for that.
I feel like shit,
I got a bloody nose.
It's like,
it's,
it's to me,
I don't understand why you would ever do it again.
I've done it before,
here and there and not too much.
I used to do it more but,
but uh,
I know you recommend an evening that one time,
too many people are scared that they're going to be like,
oh my God,
I'm addicted.
I love it.
You know?
And it's not like
I'm not as much scared of that is,
I just,
it does not appeal to me.
Needles in me sniffing something up my nose,
all that just does not like,
I don't feel like that's going to be in my zone of comfort.
Brian,
you've been sick for like five days now for four or five days.
Yeah.
Um,
do you,
do you smoke while you're sick?
No,
not at all.
No.
Well,
that's a good thing.
Like maybe you can quit now,
like maybe doing this,
you could transition over to gum or some shit.
I mean,
I guarantee you that's going to make a big difference.
Yes.
E-Cigarettes,
I guarantee that's gonna make a big difference.
That if you could do that,
that reminds me,
I brought a really tasty,
um,
we'd cigarette that I got somebody gave me yesterday,
but it's unbelievable how good it tastes.
I'm sure it doesn't get you very high,
but yeah,
it's got like a,
it almost tastes like a,
you're uh,
you know,
eating a scented candle or something.
This is a trick.
He's had that up his ass all day.
Hold it out right before the show.
I'm going to get Joe and Brian to put that in their mouth.
Obviously you,
Doug is not smoking from it first.
So something is up and even if you weren't,
okay,
alright,
I'll,
I'll show you guys.
You do this side thing where you're just like,
ah,
so it's tasty.
It's super tasted.
Did you see that by Brian?
Can you try one hit of that?
It's just vapor.
I might be sick.
Yeah,
he's sick.
You don't want to,
you don't want to pass it back to me.
I called back.
My back is soaking wet.
I don't,
I don't worry about that sort of thing enough.
I know is really con.
You're always conscious of it like diseases.
It will,
if you in a smoking circle and somebody lake looks like they're sick,
you probably wouldn't,
you wouldn't hit that.
No.
Oh,
you don't want to get that in your body.
Like that's like a strong virus,
a strong a bug.
It's quicker than a handshake,
probably quicker.
It's going to go right in.
It's going to go right and shake this guy guys,
you know,
got to Google maps and figuring out where to,
where to know.
You don't get it from the [inaudible].
It's bringing your hands to your face after you've touched other people.
Exactly.
So if you want to avoid getting sick,
one of the big ones is making a concerted effort to not touch your face and wash
your hands.
Yeah,
I do that big one.
Yeah.
I really try it like especially,
you know,
I play a lot of poker,
so I'm playing poker with other people.
You're touching all the cards all the time and then everybody at the table is
touching and nobody's gonna not play poker just because they have a cold,
a cold or something.
So like I've just trained myself to like,
I just sit there and play and I never touched my face.
That's smart at all.
That's smart.
And then wash my hands as often as possible during it.
You know,
another good thing man,
is this kind of shit,
probiotics.
This is a Kombucha.
This is the real Kombucha that was super into that for a while.
I mean,
I got to the part where I liked the taste of it,
you know,
cause you know some people they just can't get past.
I love it.
Yeah.
But did he my favorite thing to drink the very first time you drank when you
loved it?
I love it.
Interests Delicious because people usually make that face.
They make the Eqi fake drinks.
I don't drink sweet drinks.
Like I don't drink soda or very rarely I'll have a diet coke cook.
I'll treat myself if I'm out to dinner,
I'm like,
do I have a water or a diet coke?
I'm going to get crazy and have a diet coke.
But for the most part,
I don't drink sweet beverages unless they said juice.
More of those in the fridge.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Here.
I mean,
no,
no.
I'm sorry.
That's all right.
Home.
I brought it from my house.
That's what I'm saying is I try one right now because what flavors that this is
a gingerade.
I liked the,
the actually the,
I like the standard one basic.
Oh wait,
are you sure?
Thirsty for something delicious.
This is delicious.
Can I try one of those right?
Yeah.
We have those when we try that.
Coco cafe is espresso and coconut minter,
minter,
coconut water was going to say milk or water.
I was trying to figure out which one to go.
I went with the metal taste like chocolate milk.
It tastes like Yoohoo.
Yeah.
Oh,
I love you though,
Baby.
Right?
They're much healthier than you who?
Oh yeah.
It's espresso in coconut water.
It's all,
it is.
Pasteurized coconut water,
if you will.
The way to get like the sweetest,
most delicious coconut water,
you have to get companies that,
that pull it out raw.
And when you get that,
my God,
is it good?
Raw coconut water is fucking sensational,
but you don't really,
it doesn't last that long.
So they pasteurize and homogenize it so that they could stay on the shelf
longer.
And what about this,
uh,
this packaging way?
Is this a specific reason they put it in this instead of like a can or
something?
Question and you shake it up or anything?
Yeah,
shake it a little bit.
Cause it's,
you know,
it's got two things in it.
The coffee and the,
is it better for the environment,
those cardboard things?
I think so.
The plastic thing and that to me,
I don't know.
It seems it doesn't seem reusable so you can have shelf life.
Do you throw things away in your refrigerator?
Like when it's expired or do you usually come little over or you can go over
with dairy and meat but you shouldn't go over much with meat.
Should smell it.
If it smells gross to you,
that's because it is gross.
You know,
you shouldn't put,
this is the greatest thing I've ever had.
Coco cafe.
It's delicious.
It's great.
Right?
It's super delicious.
You have them as a sponsor yet?
No,
no,
they just send us from free shit.
Those caps,
man,
did she,
he's,
there's this fucking island somewhere like 2000 miles away from civilization and
all these birds are dying on this island because they're picking up shiny caps
and plastic and shit.
They find floating the off the ocean and they bring it back to their babies and
they feed it to their babies.
So you find these like skeletons and their stomachs are full of these bird.
Like,
I mean these,
uh,
pieces of plastic that it was in the birds belly,
stretch them out.
It's disgusting.
Like bottle caps and all this shiny shit plastic thing.
Remember the plastic rings you used to always have to tear them apart.
So that's,
you know,
if you cared about,
uh,
you know,
anything out in the ocean,
but the,
the,
you don't have those to do that with anymore,
but there's still plenty of crap that it's just going to get out there and get
eaten.
You know what I love?
I love when you talk about something online,
like especially do something like a podcast like this.
If you bring up a subject,
especially subject,
it's like really serious.
There's always gonna be someone comes along goes,
it's not that big a deal.
It's actually yes,
you know,
no matter how fucked up it is,
like there was a a thing on the Pacific garbage patch and we were calling an
island of garbage and they were like,
wow,
it's actually not in my husband.
Actually.
Just a bunch of stuff floating around together.
It's more like an archipelago.
I know.
It's not an Ironman,
silly goose.
That's not what's important here.
What's important here is there's a fucking bunch of garbage,
Texas size,
Hunka garbage,
all swim together and little particles that are floating around it like it's
really,
really fucking bad because we've only been putting that shit in the ocean for
200 years.
So how long do we have left?
How much ocean do we have left until the ocean is all like the fucking the,
the river right next to the Harlem.
You know,
what does that,
the East River.
Which one is that?
I the Hudson.
The Hudson.
How does that mean?
The Hudson?
It's just,
we just,
everyone knows the Hudson is polluted.
That's just it.
It's just polluted.
It's just we accept it,
we accept it.
It's right next to New York City.
There's millions of people in New York City.
There's just no way to keep their to land planes in.
Basically.
It's crazy how we just accept that that's still part of the fucking ocean.
It's a part of the fucking ecosystem.
It's right there and we just go get out of there.
That fucking river is a mess.
We just totally accept the fact that we've completely ruined a giant river.
Like that's how fucked up
be biller.
We just say,
but we're here.
We're here.
So that's fuck.
Now there's a giant river.
How's that affecting huge day to day life,
Joe?
Because out here in California,
and it was clean,
if you were in New York and it was clean,
it would be a masterpiece.
That'd be beautiful.
Clean River right next to New York City would be fucking incredible.
If it was totally removed of diseased fucking bodies that they throw out there
and all the fucking oil spills and leaks and barges flood,
it would be amazing.
It'd be amazing.
It'd be fucking an incredible place.
Like A,
a beautiful like,
like the coast of Mexico,
like could go down to like Cancun and the water's blue.
It's like so fantastic.
Imagine if that was like all the way up to they put drops in that water
or if it was just at least that quality.
I just stopped.
I stopped using eye drops because I finally,
I just finally said,
what,
who am I trying to hide it from that my eyes are red.
Like just fucking wear sunglasses,
Robin Thicke style.
They're probably disappointed when they see you clear-eyed.
That's what I mean.
Like,
you know,
it's,
it's so funny,
I can't do anything without people.
Like we were talking about you being whether you were high on news radio.
I did like this little couple line part on friends and every time it gets rerun
people write to me.
You were so high doing that.
And I was like,
no,
that was me.
But I wasn't so high.
I was at,
it was at a movie movie studio lot,
you know,
in a scene with Jennifer Aniston.
So it wasn't like I was running around the corner and hitting bowls every chance
I got at the taping,
you know,
but people just assume they're just like,
yeah,
you know,
you're so fucked up all the time.
Yeah.
Well that's your thing though,
right?
I guess do for 20 shows,
man.
You do.
Should do.
If I do encourage you,
I'm not gonna lie about that.
And My,
if you heard about my new web series,
no,
what is it?
It's called getting Doug with high.
Oh yeah,
I did hear about this and a yeah,
maybe your people might've spoken to because you know,
uh,
there's people,
it's,
I have all these shows that I booked myself
and this is finally one where the,
where the folks that are producing the show are going to book the,
uh,
the,
you know,
the guests.
And so I could still follow up and say,
Hey,
please do my show to friends of mine.
But basically I'm trying to take the booking out of my hands so it's one less
thing I have to do.
But,
so that's why you probably get a call from someone other than me.
Cause normally if I wanted you to do one of my podcasts,
I call you up and say,
dude,
Doug loves movies.
And you'd say,
I don't know that much about it.
Okay.
Thanks Joe.
All the time you did it.
Yeah.
But you didn't do it.
Didn't love it though.
You didn't love doing it.
I really love talking to you.
I really love that.
Yeah.
So we do this.
And Swim,
meet on your turf.
I would be happy to do your show,
but I just,
I don't,
can't contribute that much.
I don't know that much.
Well that's the thing about getting Doug with high is it's just we start at four
15 Pacific standard time at live streams.
I mean it's basically what you do,
but uh,
it tighter and
treating it more like a TV show.
Like it's kind of like a talk show set,
right?
Know,
like we don't have the cans on it,
but where we sit there,
me and the guest start smoking at four 20 x smoke all the way till five o'clock.
And then the last thing that happens is when we're really,
really high,
I forced them,
I forced my guest to watch a magic trick.
Whoa.
Magician runs in and does the trick for them because nothing like watching a
stoner watch a magic trick.
A really good magician.
Yeah,
he's great.
He,
you know,
is this a kid?
I know that does magic,
but he's a really good at it.
I've never been a fan of magic.
I mean either,
but I don't like being tricked.
I think it's probably because I'm a control freak.
Yeah.
That's why you hit that one show.
Punked also.
You hated that show.
Well that show is dangerous.
You cause you let,
they let people,
like there was one where,
uh,
the guy from trap traumas blink one 85.
That guy like when are you seven was,
what did they do to one 82?
Sorry,
can you take the one o two to the 10 bad ass mother fucker.
A made amazing drummer.
I just forget the band's name.
Um,
but there was some guy who got in his face and he was like ready to go.
Like,
he could have easily punched this guy.
He,
this guy was acting like a total douche bag for the show,
you know,
trying to go to him intellectually,
right?
But I'm like,
God,
this is so close like this,
this,
you know,
Travis is not a bitch.
You know,
you get in his face and start talking shit to him.
He's ready to fucking kick your ass.
He's just a regular dude with tattoos up to his chin.
All right,
he'll fuck you up.
You know,
he was ready.
And so I was like,
this is a bad situation.
Like they let it get to this.
Well,
like he got up and he was going to kick that guy's ass and I'm gonna go outside
and then,
you know,
he's like,
ah,
you're pumped.
Like,
okay,
you're lucky.
No one stabbed you.
I forgot who it was.
But Steve Razah Neesy a Radisson,
easy resin.
Nazanin as easy as easy.
He,
um,
uh,
s it didn't ever air it on punk because the,
the athlete was so,
uh,
you know,
wanting to protect his reputation,
but I forget who it was now,
but he said,
uh,
like,
you know,
a professional athlete that he went at it pretty hard,
like almost took a swing at him.
Dude,
I would not do that to a professional athlete.
God dammit.
Shit.
That's so stupid because you wake up unconscious and he's like,
dude,
I'm sorry.
I did not know you were filming a TV show and it just fucks you up.
That easily could happen.
Did you ever see the time that,
uh,
I think it was,
was it hulk Hogan drop Richard Belzer on his head?
Yeah.
He's choked him unconscious and then dropped him and then he hit his head.
God Damn Dad is scary to watch.
Dude.
J O cogans a giant.
He's a fucking giant man.
I saw him a monster.
I've,
I've met him,
obviously.
I did a,
um,
uh,
interviewed him for a,
one of the a UFC shows.
It was when he was doing TNA wrestling on spike.
Holy Shit.
He see if you find that I stepped behind them during that fight and he just
combed his hair with this little brush the whole time.
That's during the didn't really fancy.
Hold that up.
Pull it up.
Oh,
I interviewed the Hulk Hogan.
He's a giant human being,
man.
If that guy,
and this is back way back in the day,
he's had a gang of back surgeries and all sorts of other stuff go wrong with
them because of all the,
the hard days of wrestling,
you know,
I'm sure he's probably lost height because they had to,
uh,
look.
I said,
look how fucking big that dubious.
I mean,
I'm short,
but God damn,
that guy's big as fuck.
He's giant.
Yeah.
Thank you.
My brother,
you know,
to be here with Joe Mania.
It doesn't get any better than this brother.
These guys are going to war out here.
It's unbelievable.
Now you've made,
it's an intimate fights before and you want to highlight in my life,
by the way,
now I understand that you have recently announced a partnership with TNA
wrestling and it's
president Dixie Carter and you're going to be bad.
I am at reading shit off.
I've never seen you with a card out there at the fights.
They make me do that.
You know there's give you something,
hey you got to interview mostly Goldberg does these kinds of things.
I don't know why I wound up doing this one.
Maybe if I figured out like he busted ass for you so badly.
They'll eventually,
it's,
I'm fine talking to those guys.
But you know,
talking to him in a form like that we have to promote something very specific.
Yeah.
Hard to remember.
You got to have the cards.
I've got my cards on my new talk show because everybody that comes on,
you know,
they're,
they're agreeing just smoke weed on camera so at least I can do is give him a
card.
Gives an accurate plugs.
Yeah,
the trouble like the,
the Ho Ho Ho Cogan thing looks like TNA wrestling.
I really don't pay attention to wrestling.
So if you want me to read something about wrestling,
you gotta tell him you'd probably look down just to catch TNA.
You're probably like,
it's some sort of wrestling with initials.
But if it was like an MMA bout,
I wouldn't need any notes at all.
You'd never seen him with notes.
If Hawk Koch came on,
he was talking about fighting Brock Lesnar in a real cage fight.
There would be no,
yeah,
you can just go out there and do it.
It would be pretty simple.
That goes of giant dude though.
If he choked your head and let you go like that,
that's dangerous.
So like I,
I enjoyed that punk show,
but I was like,
yikes.
This is this.
Don't even enjoy watching it because I'm just makes me like,
even though there's always the reveal of the PR person finding out that got
pumped to go,
ah,
it's still like they reach a level of ugliness that like,
you know,
I would hate to reach well,
uh,
being filmed,
you know,
and,
and have a couple of times,
but too many violent people.
Yeah,
I know too many people that would fuck you up if you did something like that and
then wouldn't even think that there was anything wrong with fucking you up cause
thought you were probably going to fuck them up.
Yeah.
Why?
Why wait for that to happen?
Why wait to get fucked up?
Timberlake?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's like sitting on the curb crying at one point.
We shouldn't show it.
He's,
we don't own them anyway,
but yeah,
and we're not talking nice about it.
Well then they got away with it.
But look,
I should talk because we got away with a ton of Shit on fear factor we should
have never done did what they did is nothing compared to what we did on fear
factor.
So I really should shut the fuck up.
Like we had people ride bulls that was that you didn't like show you didn't
like,
you know,
show up at their place of work and it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It's just a TV show.
Justin Timberlake.
It was stoned while being punked by Ashton Kutcher.
That's,
that was his excuse
for crying about losing all of this stuff.
He said he gave up marijuana after that episode of punk.
Oh,
well then you know what?
That's bullshit.
That is Wiki.
He's the,
he's the punk bleaching.
You could use.
We could use a guy like Justin Timberlake on our side.
Trust me,
dude.
It ain't bad.
You were freaked out because they were punking you man,
an act of aggression.
Plus you're super duper duper duper famous.
I think he's still smokes.
I think that was just,
uh,
you know,
I mean snoop Dogg has had a press release saying he stopped smoking.
That was a while ago.
But it's still like anybody who says that,
it's like,
well,
for now,
for us,
for,
for a reason,
they're requesting for a reason,
but they'll be back a post saying,
I ran into post saying it Disneyland.
Oh yeah.
How was he?
He's back on the weed.
Well,
I saw him in a comedy festival.
So of course hanging out with the other comics,
how do the road,
he's going to do something.
But I respect the fact that he realized that he needed to get his shit together,
you know?
And so that was like sort of his thing.
Like once you got to shit back in line,
he just felt like he was using it a little bit too much and it's like you know,
high around his kid all the time.
That's got it.
You got,
you want to be present for your children.
Yeah.
And you also want to make sure that you know you're not out of control.
You know,
you don't want that feeling of whether whatever it is,
if it's fucking coffee,
if you're down in coffee all day every day and you just get up in the morning
and you just Zombie towards that coffee,
slow down,
stop taking it or judge anyone for for not smoking or never smoking like a,
that's part of the thing to me.
Like it's always amazing to me.
Like,
I'll get messages from people on like I could smoke you under the table.
And I'm like,
so like that's,
that's what smoking weed is about.
That's a new being the best at it.
Being aggressive about it.
Like,
no,
it's about having fun and enjoying yourself dudes though.
Everything's about that.
Well,
sure that some people are just so tightly wound that even weeds not going to,
you know,
relax him that much.
But I think it helps everybody that,
that,
you know,
most people that use it,
it can be overused.
Like anything.
Yeah,
it certainly can.
But you're right about most people,
a lot of people rather being tightly wound that the idea,
I mean that's part of why I like it is cause I'm kind of a nervous,
anxious person by nature and uh,
you know,
smoking all the time just helps me to just relax and not worry about shit so
much.
I still worry about it.
It's not like I'm checking out completely,
you know what I mean?
It's more like you're just opening your mind to,
you know,
lots of stuff and hopefully you know enough good stuff that uh,
you can not worry the other when you have
Jesus Christ,
you've got so many ideas right now flowing.
None of trying to catch salmon.
Yeah.
I'm just saying that it,
like,
it not only relaxes me,
but it also helps me to write and think of things and you know,
oh most definitely it,
you know,
it's not,
it's not all just one thing that it does.
No,
I think it's very
beneficial.
But I think the people develop patterns and sometimes those patterns get out of
control.
It's really easy for a person,
especially of comedic tendencies.
Someone who's got that kind of impulsive nature to them anyway,
they can just get out of control with something.
So sometimes it's good to just write the ship,
you know?
So sometimes it's good when a guy does that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
He was smoking all day every day.
Like I,
there's some days where I'll wake up and I'll sit around for a while and I won't
smoke cause I tend 20 it's not like,
oh I just woke up,
I have to do this,
you know what I have to do to get through the day.
It's not,
I never have that feeling about it,
you know?
It's more like I'll do it when I do it.
Do you see the thing about the Tsa,
Tsa is going to let people bring weed on planes,
but how much and where from anywhere to anywhere.
Because a lot of states it's still illegal to wear the,
the idea being that there,
it's going to be a don't ask,
don't tell sort of situation and a,
if you're bringing,
we'd say if you have a license in Massachusetts and he also have a license in
Los Angeles,
you find from Los Angeles where you have a license to Massachusetts where you
have a license,
you're good to go.
I think you can only get a license in the state you live in though.
Is that true?
I think so.
We need to buy real estate and other places,
Bro Ball or if you want to fly with weed,
do you still have property in Colorado?
Is that why?
Imagine if you did that,
get a fucking a house you kept everywhere and every state just so you could fly
with your weed.
That would be the ultimate baller legal in every state.
And I got a f B could still do it anyway.
Yeah.
I mean I don't recommend flying with a lot of it,
but the TSA is not,
they're not,
their job is not defined.
It's not to,
you know,
uh,
Gilligan arrest people for minor drug crimes.
Like they're looking for shit that's going to cause everybody to die to die.
Yeah.
But they have busted people before.
I mean Warwick got caught with a bunch of joints in her.
Um,
it was like a lipstick case.
How long ago was that?
Oh,
I think it's been a while.
Cause like,
cause like you don't hear of celebrity pot busts that much anymore.
And um,
you know,
if they were still going on you would hear even more about them cause he's TMZ
and everything.
That's just looking for those stories,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I definitely think that they're looking for weapons.
One,
they're looking for anything,
but I go to the airport a lot.
I've never seen anybody pulled aside for,
for anything but like it,
you know,
fully what they do is they call the cops
never see actual cops cruising around in the airport that much other than,
you know,
driving and driving around outside.
Like they don't let you know,
they don't like cars to stop.
And you know when they're picking people up,
the cops keep it moving.
Well it depends on where you are.
If you're in Texas,
you very well could see that.
Not only that,
you could see someone going to jail for weed for real,
no doubt about it.
If they pull you over for a stop violation and they find weed on you,
there's a lot of cops that have put you in jail in Texas.
Absolutely.
That's legit.
California.
The laws are so lenient right now that we have the medical marijuana and then we
also have decriminalization.
That's Arnold Schwarzenegger pass that when he got it office quietly nice and
silent,
it was the best thing that he ever did.
And uh,
what it means is that you can't go to jail for it,
which is,
you know,
makes sense.
It's fucking ridiculous.
We're still in this weird sort of a wrestling match with a,
with reality when it comes to that
easy way to round up people that aren't white is what these minor drug offenses
are.
The prisons are full of people that are Hispanic and black and they had three
strikes that are all just like a,
you know,
three pot things in a row or something.
And now they're in jail.
Yeah.
The uh,
the isn't private prison industry is a ve.
What are you doing Brian?
That's the tug.
Benson,
the OCULUS rift.
This has absolutely nothing to do with what we're talking about,
but it is,
but it is funny.
Brian made a vine of me wearing the oculus.
There's nothing to do.
What?
We're talking crazy glasses.
Yeah.
But it was,
it was funny when it happened cause I didn't know he was filming me.
There's a,
there was an article on boiling,
boiling the other day about prison profiteers extracting billions by exploiting
prisoners and their families.
It's really fucking scary shit.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know how much the,
the,
the prison system influences the way laws are formed,
but the idea that they could possibly do that at all.
It's really creepy.
The idea that you're benefiting from people being in new jails,
profiting from people,
being in your jails and spending money to try to promote laws that would keep
people from getting away with certain crimes so that you can profit off of them.
Yeah.
Like you're,
you're trying to make things illegal
as long.
And we all know while they're there,
whatever,
whatever criminal acts did,
they don't know how to do or haven't done.
They learn all about it while they're in prison.
This is very scary.
And then they go back out and they,
that's all they know what it,
what else they gonna do.
Yeah.
It's really fucking stranger.
And then there's also,
they're talking about the,
the issue with people getting sick and in prison they're talking about the,
it says the cruelty,
the prison medical contractors who ration vital treatments to prisoners,
leaving them in agony and worse.
For example,
correctional medical services discourages treatment for hepatitis,
leaving prisoners with Hep C to slide into permanent profound disability.
Wow,
that's insane.
Super messed up.
That's insane.
Like they,
they put you in a cage and then they don't provide you with medical attention if
you're dying of a curable disease or at least a treatable disease,
that's fucking scary.
That means they're not responsible for keeping you a healthier,
alive.
Like they can just treat you as a subhuman and put you in a cage.
I mean,
I guess maybe it would depend on what kind of a person you are.
If you're some guy went into a school and just start shooting kids.
Yeah.
I don't really think you should get any fucking medicine,
but that's a very rare,
small segment of our population.
There really should be snuffed out.
Like there's no sense in keeping those people alive.
Like God kind of
situation.
Someone he is fucking mass shooter,
he's,
he's about to go out and do that sort of thing again someday if f ever or
they're just going to sit in jail for the rest of it.
Like it's just a waste of everybody's time and money.
So when this horrible,
horrible person can,
yeah,
I mean,
so anybody else that's,
you're not treating like,
what do you do?
You're going to let them die and fall apart of something that you've got the
medicine right there and you could just give it to him,
like how much money you guys make per prisoner or how much money is this fucking
thing make a year?
Like what's going on here?
You guys are making how much you guys are making millions and millions and
millions of dollars off of prisons.
Like it's a money generating machine that's fucking terrifying.
That said,
if they're like rapists or murderers,
it's not going to,
I'm,
you know,
I'm not going to feel more people that we have more people in prison and per
capita than any other,
any other country.
And it's by,
it's by far.
It's not just by a small margin.
Oh,
it's a massive amount.
Yeah,
But you know,
the argument is that's also why America is so safe.
Whom a man,
no place is safe.
Well,
when you're,
when you're around other human beings.
Yeah.
Well when there's disparity and when,
when there's poverty and when there's people that are ignored and marginalized,
that's the,
you know,
there's an issue in this country where everybody's like,
hey,
people should pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
And I agreed to do a certain extent.
I agree.
If your conditions are optimal,
if you don't have health issues,
if you are not in a terrible violent neighborhood trapped in this horrible
school system,
if all those factors aren't,
then yeah,
you should probably pull yourself by your bootstraps.
Stop fucking crying.
Cause you could be one of those kids.
You can be someone whose situation is fucked from the jump and there's nothing
you can do about it.
Everyone's abusing you.
You've got people hitting you,
there's violence around you.
You,
you don't know what you don't know how to read.
You're a fucked,
your whole situation is fucked.
To tell those people to pull themselves up by their bootstraps,
who's going to teach them how to do that?
Who's going to teach them how to develop character?
Who's going to teach them to eliminate bad behavior patterns?
You know,
how fucking difficult it is to change a person as opposed to develop a person.
It's insanely difficult.
So in that sense,
we're really ridiculous that we ignore the impoverished sections of our cities.
It's ridiculous to allow that to ever happen.
That should never be taken place.
And everybody was like,
Ooh,
to youtube,
you know,
idea.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And it's,
by the way,
it's not like putting people on fucking Mars.
It's a utopian concept that can be achieved.
It's a utopian concept that using a fraction of the money we use to support
these fucking corrupt dictators all throughout the world,
a fraction of that could clean up every fucking city in America easily,
easily.
You know,
people say that,
you know,
people,
people think that the idea of food stamps is that those people are all just uh,
you know,
living on the Dole or whatever and just like kicking back and getting the money
and it's like a dollar 50 per person in your family per day is not,
you're not living the life you're struggling to get by and you're probably all
fat because the food you're eating is all just disgusting.
You know,
dollar burgers at Mcdonald's and that's the shit you're feeding to your kids
because you can't,
it's like Eh,
it's,
the system is set up to keep the poor to create more poor.
I don't think it's set up that way.
I think it take it,
it just isn't that way.
Yeah.
It takes
vantage of poor people and poor people also get stuck in a Rut.
I mean,
it's true.
We don't have a class system in this country and this is a country where a
person can be poor and can be really good at something and then eventually want
to being a wealthy person because of that.
This is a very rare situation.
Like that where like a rapper can go from being like in a impoverished
neighborhood to being like a celebrity,
like a Jay z guy who like a great sports.
Yeah.
And then export to some extent,
you know,
other forms of performing,
but it's,
but it's hard to,
how do you develop that skill if you're poor and you have to,
you know,
work all the time or be starving all the the
time and you and you all have any guide.
You don't have role models.
Like we need to learn from older people.
And like I said before,
it's way harder to change someone once they become a certain way,
it's way hard to accept that you are fucking up,
that your personality has holes in it,
that you,
you know,
you're,
you're psychotic,
you're abusive,
you're manipulative,
like whatever it is that's wrong with you.
You can't be told that things might be him.
I had to go without become you become defensive.
Almost everybody does.
Yeah.
They don't want to hear it.
And so changing.
It's super fucking hard to do.
But when someone who inspires you and you're around people that are admirable
and someone cares about you and they show you the benefits of living a certain
way,
they instruct you on the benefits of being positive and friendly that you could
change in time,
generations,
just massive change throughout our entire country.
If we just established some community centers where we made sure there was
plenty of cops around,
that everything was safe.
We cut way back on the crime by putting money into these areas and making areas
where people can feel safe,
where kids can feel safe after school,
where they're going to meet like counselors and and and,
and coaches and people that were happy to be working there.
Helping these young kids and teaching them how to play a gang games,
get along with each other,
teaching a little bit about character and and having a place where they know
that they don't have to worry.
They're going to get food for sure.
They're going to get someone who cares about them for sure.
They're going to get people that can instruct them and various elusive aspects
of life.
When you're a young man or a young woman and you're growing up in a terrible
neighborhood,
we don't take care of that.
And that's one of the reasons why we have to worry about bad neighborhoods.
It's one of the reasons why we have to worry about poverty.
It's because people have just been fucking shit on from the moment that they
came out of their mother's womb.
They just never got a break.
And that's not fair.
And they see people like you or like I or like,
you know,
a nice white people that live in Nice neighborhoods that have never really
experienced anything horrible like that and they almost feel like you stole
something.
You feel like you stole something from him.
Why us?
Why instead of them?
Exactly.
It's all just cosmic a luck of the draw.
But it seems like it's the Utopian concept is achievable in that way,
that you can at least have a massive impact on the society if you started taking
care of its young a little bit better or helping them taking care of its young,
relieving a little bit of the burden,
you know?
And the idea that it creates more welfare.
Welfare creates more welfare and you know,
people creates people that can't help themselves.
It doesn't have to be,
it's not,
it does not have to be that you either.
There's,
there can be a way to do it where you're trying to help people help themselves
and it's just set up like that.
The amount of money we spend and rebuilding places that we explode is fucking
staggering.
When you look at the amount of money like military contractors got for
rebuilding Iraq and they just built shit that they didn't even need like water
treatment plants like well we got to build once,
we're going to put one right here.
I got a contract to do this.
Like there was a lot of complaints about that kind of shit.
It's just like they had these,
they had to spend an x amount of money to justify the amount of money that was
coming to them.
So they're constantly,
you know,
do shit machines.
The newest TSA machines are all,
that's some government contract paid for those and paid off somebody to supply
all the airports with them.
You know the ones that we have to stand with your hands over your head.
Not only that,
the guy who sold it to them,
one of the machines,
at least he used to work for the TSA.
He's be like the president of the Tsa and then he leaves.
He makes us fucking machine that's involved in cells into the Tsi.
It's like what the hell?
But the TSA is not like a government organization.
The TSA is like private organization.
So that's,
it's actually a normal thing.
I think it's government because they're checking your shit and they're going
through your underwear and stuff,
but it's really not.
It's like they work for the government.
Yeah.
So that's why like if you had some weed on you,
they'd have to call a cop.
They can't arrest you,
they can't do shit.
I think they just say,
you know,
they bring a cop over.
They'd know.
They say throw it out or something that you hope.
No,
I mean that's the anecdotally,
that's what I always hear is that that's the worst thing that happens.
But also again,
it's,
these are white friends of mine with a very small amount of weed on them.
Yeah.
And it's probably happening in California and mean El Paso.
And it's like,
like you were saying earlier though,
I mean it's going to,
there's definitely like,
I think that Oregon and Washington and um,
maybe Colorado,
maybe all of those,
you can fly from state to state if you have a card in one of them.
I think,
uh,
yeah,
those two things.
I don't want to hear what I'm getting on a plane with weed maybe.
And I
think possibly that sounds like a disaster,
but that's,
so that's the trouble with hanging out with stoners though and talking to him
about these things is people will tell you emphatically things that aren't,
aren't true.
You know?
Like they'll still just say,
no,
you can,
you got your card.
You could definitely fly there.
And they don't.
That's something they heard from another dude.
Well tell me if the,
you think this is true because one of those,
do you think that,
I've read this online and I'm very curious because I think I might be just
feeding this problem that this uh,
US shutdown the shutdown of the U S it has driving traffic to sugar daddy sites
and the sugar daddy sites.
A sugar daddy side is where like a girl can go and like people can like bid on
taking her on a date.
I guess.
I like old rich dudes who got some fucking billionaire.
Dude's got some cash and all of us and I'm just looking at your profile.
I'll pay your rent.
Like what's up?
Like let's work something out.
Yeah,
they went up 50% why?
I Dunno,
that's my question.
Do you think that that's true or do you think that that's a really smart
business move by this company to release a press statement saying that their
business went up 50% because we're talking about them.
We're talking about him now.
New sponsors that you're not known.
No sponsor.
I'm just confused.
What would the,
what would the direct connection be between the shutdown?
Exactly that going up because it's like all the shutdown has done is furloughed
a lot of people that probably are orange and we never will be sugar daddies and
it's not necessarily making the people that are rich more money because of the
shutdown.
Is it a no,
I think the idea is that there's a bunch of people that don't have jobs now and
so they have nothing better to do than go and bid on dates.
No,
no,
no.
The girls that girls like what you're seeing more girls are going there.
More girls are checking it out.
Exactly.
Imagine that these girls are falling the news closely enough to,
to know that the government might,
is shutting down,
that we might default on the,
on the debt.
I don't know.
I really,
And that they're that panicked about it,
what it's gonna do to them directly.
Well,
it could be that someone who is already financially in a bad situation and then
they see something like that starting to panic because you know,
Obama saying stuff like we might go into a worse for a session and the one we
were just in exactly.
If we don't settle this debt ceiling thing.
So yeah.
Uh,
so that's possible.
I thought you meant that there's more guys money with money trying to get these
girls,
but it just seems like a,
not a coincidence,
but it just seems like,
you know,
it's probably going to be on a steady rise for a while until the economy gets
better.
They're saying,
they're saying it's sudden.
They're saying it's a sudden spike.
Yes.
They're saying 50% jump since the government shutdown.
I don't know if the,
I can't see those two being connected.
I Dunno.
Join one of those websites recently.
Joe,
did you really seeking arrangement.com and what you do is,
is this a fucking telling us all about it?
Yeah.
And if you use the coupon code,
no,
but uh,
and uh,
it's so weird,
man.
Like there's this people that you just tell them like how much money you make
and do this and that is a tank you,
it seems like there would be a smart move if you were just looking to find
people to meet that or it seems like a website in your money.
No.
What is it only your running pretty much entering anything else?
Like what you do or what your interest story.
You don't have to write anything.
Wife,
I've have so many messages since I just recently did this as a joke and I only
have one photo and it's a blurry photo cause I didn't want anyone to see that.
Your real name?
Uh,
no.
And it's like that's my photo look up blurry that is blurred.
I 10 I'm sorry.
Start trolling you dummy.
Why wasn't really using this as like,
I'm going to even check it.
I forgot all about it.
But anyway,
my point is do you think that there's a panic in the air and that's why the
sugar daddy websites get an upswing of traffic?
That's the idea.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe more women or giving women and giving up.
It's not just,
you can say,
well,
giving up on the idea of just,
you know,
rolling.
I don't want to say that they're not willing to willing or able to stand on
their own,
but they're just,
there seems to be some women in society that are,
they're fine with the idea of,
you know,
meeting a man with some money and not,
and then just doing whatever.
You know,
they're not necessarily both the guys nice.
Yeah.
But they're not necessarily like Wah,
but every woman I meet seems to not be interested in,
in money these days.
But that's,
that just might be just because with a bunch of liars.
I mean,
nobody's ever,
I don't feel like anybody's ever come on to me because I have a little bit of
money.
Well,
you're a smart guy.
He's not hanging around with a bunch of assholes,
but without the bow,
there are people that will hang out with you just because they think that
somehow know that they could profit from it.
You know,
you could,
you could definitely stumble into the wrong crowd and you,
you,
you haven't,
you certainly could.
This is a weird thing where people worry about what other people do for money.
Like uh,
uh,
if there's some Gal who's a married to some 60 year old guy and she's 24 and
she's driving a Ferrari and you're like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
Like what do you care?
Like why would you care at all?
Why would you care what she does?
Why would you care what he,
those two are working it out and chances are,
you know,
especially the guys probably also still kind of miserable,
because it's not,
it's not a real relationship,
but it's the fuck knows that's what he's settling for or what he was enjoying at
the time.
So why not?
It is possible.
It's also possible that they like each other.
That's possible too.
It's not as likely,
but it's possible.
They like each other for,
for reasons.
You know,
she's hot and he's got money,
you know,
that they,
they both get something out of it.
She struggled,
you know,
and he,
he's a materialist and he likes taking care of people.
It makes them feel good.
I do fall into matters very much like taking care of people.
Do you like it
that though?
Just because you're nice,
you know,
because it is a nice thing to be able to help someone out.
When you meet someone and you see that they're struggling and help them.
It's a nice feeling to be able to do
well.
I had an idea when you were talking about earlier about why,
why not start like a Joe Rogan,
a fight camps.
Underprivileged
kids.
Good idea.
You want to organize it president?
Yeah,
I know right now the scammers will start coming up.
That's another thing.
You have to be really careful about getting weird things that people come up to
you with like they,
well,
any charities like the where you want to find out when you get involved in a
charity,
whether or not it's legit because unfortunately there have been illegit
charities.
I've retweeted things sometimes because I think,
you know,
pulls on my heartstrings and I'm like,
I'll try to help these people and then I immediately get all these emails back.
That place is a scam.
That's a,
that's a,
you just gave me a virus.
You fuck yeah.
Or whatever it is.
Yeah.
It's uh,
so it's,
it's hard to not,
you know,
retweet those things.
But what do you remember Kony?
Remember Kony 2000 watts?
One of the examples where people are all over my shit.
Just cause I tried to help,
I just watched the video and was moved by it and it was like,
okay,
everybody should watch this.
And then immediately,
oh that guy.
Yeah.
A few weeks later he's running around naked in the streets.
That was,
that was one of my favorite moments in all of civilization because it was so
absurd.
It was so quick,
immediate,
all encompassing.
Everyone was Kony.
2012 there was bumper stickers and tee shirts.
I saw them everywhere.
I saw posters.
I saw so much about it in the news.
I saw it on websites all the time.
And then boom,
gone.
I mean,
in a flash it was the flavor of the month.
Literally it lasted about a month and after it was over,
millions of dollars had been exchanged.
One guy had ran around beating off in the street naked and you never heard from
him or anything to do with it ever again.
You're coneys just still doing his thing,
I guess.
I don't know what the fuck he was doing in the first place.
Isn't that place like flooded with guys like that?
I think so.
I think that's what part of it was.
It's like,
you know,
oh sure.
That's,
that's a good cause,
but that's not going to solve the overall problem and that there's many,
you know,
evil people like that.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
Africa is,
why don't we say that?
If you want to find the apocalypse,
you can find it right now.
2013 in Africa.
Like if you watched that vice documentary on Liberia,
have you ever seen that captain or a general butt naked duties to take off all
his clothes and run naked and fucking killing people in war would eat children's
hearts.
Cut the enemy's children's heart,
take their children,
cut their hair down,
eat it.
See,
that's a guy that just needs to find weed and just,
he's still alive.
Fuck down.
He's responsible for thousands of deaths,
including children that he ate,
ate their hearts,
still alive and was forgiven because now he's a Christian preacher.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
People are trying to crop,
you know,
they're trying again.
He's so he's,
you know,
it's like he's a different person.
Came out of his mother's vagina all over again,
but it's a,
when you watched them interviewing him,
man in Liberia,
it's fucking crazy.
That was our boy Shane.
I bought,
it was like one of the best,
most like in depth pieces I've ever seen on a country in massive turmoil where
this guy,
general butt naked was talking about how he knows what human flesh tastes like.
And he found a vendor that was selling meat on the corner.
It was human flesh and he had to tell the police because he knows what flesh
tastes like.
Like he's eating so many people,
he knows what people tastes like.
So when they're serving people,
it was like,
this is not cow.
This is people.
And then he brings over the cops and they arrest that guy.
Meanwhile,
he's eating babies and because he's got a Bible there,
letting him run the streets.
That's way crazier than Matt backs that.
That's way crazier than Thunderdome.
Two men,
one man leap,
he eight babies,
k,
he cut their hearts out and now he talks about an old,
he reads from an old book.
And because of that he's allowed to just roam the streets.
You're responsible for thousands of deaths.
It's a,
it's a crazy place,
man.
That's a cro.
Raise the place.
He and he was forgiven.
Did you,
uh,
have you heard about that movie?
The act of killing?
MMM.
What is this?
These old genocidal dudes that were involved in genocides are like telling the
stories and reenacting,
uh,
the,
the way Cambodia way they kill people.
Yeah.
And it's,
uh,
it's supposedly,
I mean it's,
everyone says it's a great film,
but I haven't watched it yet because it just sounds so horrible to see these
people who got away with this shit bragging about it.
You know,
I can't do that,
man.
I can't,
you know,
just to be a great film though.
Oh,
I'm sure it's great.
But I did this because they get these guys to shit.
They get these guys to reenact scenes where they killed people,
like using old movies,
like,
you know,
like Scarface,
shut down,
please shut this off.
Oh,
is that what it is to Brian?
Put it up there.
I don't want to watch that,
but it's a,
yeah,
that movie's really,
uh,
people described as an extremely intense experience.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Human beings are incredible,
incredible,
weird things and what we're capable of.
Some really fucking heinous things.
Really heinous acts.
Yeah.
And it,
could that ever change?
Is it possible for what's definitely changing?
There's way less of it.
Sure.
I think if you look at the actual numbers of human beings in comparison to what
they were just a hundred years ago or 200 years ago,
and then you factor in the amount of death and murder and chaos,
and it's probably safer now than ever before.
Probably.
Maybe,
maybe debatable,
you know,
because now we can wipe out the larger numbers quicker.
Everybody lives longer for sure.
For sure.
So,
you know,
it's,
it's very debatable,
but there's,
there's still no question that there's areas of the world right now where they
live in,
in justice,
chaotic,
uh,
situation and the,
as has ever existed,
but the people in Africa,
like he's perfectly example,
Somalia,
all those people that,
uh,
were forced to become pirates because,
all their,
uh,
fishing waters were polluted by a European businesses that with Tom Hanks looks
intense,
very intense.
The origin of that,
you know,
they call themselves the volunteer coast guard of Somalia,
that's what they call themselves.
They all started doing that because these fucking guys had no fish anymore.
These Europeans would dump waste off the shore and just polluted everything,
killed everything.
And so these poor fucking people,
they started kidnapping.
These boat captains had dumped his stuff off the shore.
They would find them,
they would find the oil slick and follow the bone.
Yeah,
they,
uh,
started getting way,
way more money doing that than they ever got fishing.
So they're like,
fuck fishing.
And they just became kidnappers and now they're just these gangster crazy fucks
that have nothing to lose.
And they're on this thing called cat,
which is a,
it's,
it's a,
it's a leave that you chew and it's got like a narcotic effect,
like a stimulant effect,
not narcotic,
like a almost like amphetamines and they chew that shit and it makes them
bonkers.
So the eighth is drug.
They,
they're literally method out with submachine guns.
Yeah.
True trigger happy trigger.
Have nothing.
No doubt.
I guess in like a,
in some cases they've got,
you know,
if they kill everybody then they,
then they're,
they're cutting into how much money they could potentially make.
Right.
Cause they,
cause they hold these things for ransom so they can't,
they can't kill everybody.
But they still probably are so crazy that sometimes,
you know,
it's hard to keep control of all your,
your men.
Right,
exactly.
I'm sure there's situations like that.
This captain Phillips movie,
it's the same guy who did those first two born movies and uh,
and the,
uh,
United whatever the flight number was.
I can't,
I don't know why.
I can't ever remember that.
I guess cause it's such an unpleasant idea that the movie was named after a
flight that crashed.
What was it?
[inaudible] 93 Paul Greengrass did that.
And so this is going to be the same level of intensity I think.
Have you seen gravity dog?
You sound like a guy who loves movies.
Have you seen gravity?
I think you'd like that.
Yeah,
you'll love it.
And people were given Neil degrasse Tyson shit on Twitter,
man.
Oh cause he,
cause he said things are inaccurate or something.
It,
who cares?
What if you know him,
he would have said those things with a big smile on his face.
Yeah,
I don't mind.
Miss said that he enjoyed it.
I don't,
yeah,
I don't mind that he's pointing out the inaccuracies.
I just say who cares?
Because it's like,
it's one of those things where the movie just has to get me to a point where I
believe what's happening in the movie.
You know,
that it's,
it's telling a good story and it doesn't seem fake or stupid,
you know?
And I'm just a layman,
Yeah.
Well,
that's what people are giving him a hard time about.
Like lawyers can't watch
not having a suspension of disbelief for a movie like this.
Yeah.
And people were making fun of them saying like,
you're always the guy who's trying to,
uh,
push science and here's a movie that shows space and that you weren't into it.
It's really interesting.
I was reading these people,
uh,
attacking him,
but
he,
he's right.
First of all,
everything he's saying is correct.
And if he was saying it in front of you,
he would be smiling and you would love it.
Like a lot is lost
in text,
especially when he said that it was a good movie.
Yeah.
It's a fun movie.
But you know,
a lawyer goes to any movie that takes place in a courtroom,
they're going to tell you every fucking thing that's not accurate.
And then it's the power of that individual movie to overcome that.
You know,
like it's,
it's just a version of space that's being sold to us for entertainment.
You know,
it's not a documentary.
He wrote my tweets after everybody went after him.
He wrote my tweets hardly ever convey opinion,
mostly perspectives on the world.
But if you must know I enjoyed gravity very much so.
He just enjoys gravity every day cause he would hate to just float away.
He's giving you a fax.
Me like mysteries of gravity,
nearly all satellites order,
orbit,
Earth West to east.
Yet all satellite debris portrayed orbited east to west.
Okay.
He's just right.
It's only saying,
I mean,
and there's nothing,
it's not going to ruin my,
my enjoyment of the movie.
I remember there was a movie a long time ago called crack Atella east of Java
about a volcano and crack Atalla is west of Java.
It's just wrong right there in the title.
Yeah,
so little then there's not much gravity and gravity as it turns out in the
streets of gravity.
Why bullocks hair,
otherwise convincingly zero in in otherwise convincing zero g scenes did not
float freely on her head.
So he's just basically,
he was talking about the actual scientific inaccuracy in the movie.
She looks good when she's floating around in her little like a sports outfit.
Basically my take is if you're going to fucking make a movie like this,
talk to Neil degrasse Tyson first,
throw homeboy a couple grand and give him the script and said,
Hey Dawg,
let us know if there's some shit in here that doesn't fly because you're talking
about fucking science and he's an astrophysicist.
I mean,
he's the guy who's going to know about it,
but you know,
no,
I mean,
I don't want to watch it.
Knows the difference when the degree he knows you're just going,
Holy Shit,
look at that debris that's crashing into them.
It's so exciting.
But couldn't it have just been the right way?
It couldn't have been west to east or whichever one was the right way.
I don't know.
Why wouldn't,
why not do it that way?
We've got to talk to Alphonso Kieron maybe it's a alternate universe where Chris
is our universe.
This didn't really happen.
And the alternate universe,
it travels in a different direction and uh,
the g zero g has no effect on your hair and the alternate universe.
Maybe they just got super dope hairspray in the future and just slapped that
bitch on.
And no matter how much the wind blows,
it just looks so natural and sits there perfectly.
It's like a shield.
She's a me.
I just wasn't really looking at her hair personally.
What were you looking at her feet?
Like little outfit.
She's actually,
her haircut makes her look like she's wearing like a green shirt and she has a
haircut,
so she kind of looks like Peter Pan Floating around.
But um,
but she's still,
uh,
I,
I've always liked Sandra Bullock as a person and as a,
you know,
I've always thought she was attractive,
but man,
she dumb movies all the time,
so I'm just excited.
She's in a good one.
Something that I like and it's only 90 minutes long.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
So you didn't like that cop movie with her and the dude from [inaudible],
Mike and Molly.
The dude or the girl?
Russell McCarthy.
I haven't seen that one.
I meant to cause I like bridesmaids and the director Paul Feig,
but I,
uh,
the dude from Mike and Molly's excellent.
My friend Billy,
Billy Guardiola.
Super Nice Guy.
Very good dude.
Crazy funny guy.
Yeah,
he's a sweetheart.
Yeah.
I love that guy.
So yeah.
Um,
she,
I think she's very funny,
but um,
I didn't see that identity thief movie that she was in because it got such bad
reviews.
Oh yeah.
That looked like ass.
Yeah.
But the heat looks okay.
It looks fun.
I just haven't seen it yet.
What were the chick like that like really over the top hilarious.
Like it's all about finding the right vehicle.
There's no stuff that many fucking vehicles.
No,
that's part of the problem is that they're just,
you know,
they're just going to throw,
she's going to make two or three movies a year and a summer going to be better
than others.
This is also when you start making a movie,
you think it's going to be really good and then halfway and you're like,
oh,
this is a wretched piece of shit I'm involved in.
I mean,
that can happen.
Jason Bateman has been in a lot of crappy comedies,
but there's hardly a funnier comedic actor.
He just,
you know,
he's just got to be in the,
it's impossible to just be in good ones.
Yeah.
That's why it sucks being an actor,
man.
You've got to wait around for someone to give you a good role.
He drew,
that's a Bateman,
just switched over to,
he directed his,
uh,
most recent movie that's called bad words and I guess people loved it at the
Toronto Film Festival.
He's a famous guy and a very successful guy.
He can do stuff like that,
but to be irregular actor trying to make it like God damn.
What a grind.
It just waiting to get picked up,
waiting for someone to say,
you can do it and there's so many and bonds on wiring.
Here's the real fucking problem.
It ain't that hard.
It ain't that fucking hard.
You can take athletes and they can act and do a really fucking good job.
How about that?
How about,
how about,
you know,
people have done acting in a big movie for the first time and kicked ass.
It's happened several times,
way more than anyone's ever done that then an actor has ever played in the NBA
and kick some fucking ass.
That shit never happened once.
It's not in the history of the universe,
but athletes have gone over and acted very successfully and it looks good.
You know,
I mean,
even like pro wrestlers,
you know,
like,
like we're talking about Hulk Hogan due to Hong Kong and can act.
I mean,
he acts over the top most of the time,
but if you gave them a role where it was actually acting,
I bet he could pull it off quite nicely.
Dice was great in the new Woody Allen movie.
Nice is not an athlete.
I don't know where you're going with this because he's a big guy who's like,
you know,
I mean,
I've always thought he was a good actor,
but he hasn't,
he obviously hasn't had the greatest acting career and,
uh,
I thought he was really good in the movie.
I heard it was amazing.
My point was just that not only,
you know,
can the individual probably learn pretty easily how to act,
but also that,
uh,
performances could be gotten by a good directors.
Yes.
Ken,
you know,
obviously they have a choice of different takes and different reads and stuff
and they can,
they can make somebody that's not that great at its still look pretty good.
That's certainly possible.
Especially if someone works hard at it,
which is what a lot of athletes have done.
You know,
a lot of athletes work hard,
you know,
so you
not everybody can give like Daniel Day Lewis performances like he does in
Lincoln and my left foot because what actors are being are our winning roles
where they don't look or sound anything like the character they're going to be
playing there only being cast because of how brilliant they are.
And everyone knows that they'll get there,
that they'll make it work.
You know,
like him and Sean Penn and a couple of others.
lately Al Pachino seems to put it on a different crazy wig for every,
you know,
every movie where he's playing a real life person.
But he,
they all act like Pachino,
you know,
but it's like a great acting is like the really,
really great acting.
Most actors don't get that much opportunity to do that.
Kind of writing those roles and transforming into something else.
And there was no one else got to,
no one got to audition to play a raging bull.
You know what I mean?
Dinero said,
I'll get in the weight,
let's just do this.
Right.
He goes,
those roles are going to go to someone who's like a huge draw.
Those roles are going to go,
the first person is going to get it.
It's like a Russell Crowe type character or you know,
reputation is helpful too.
Like Sam Rockwell works a lot because he's always great even though he's still
not a household name,
you know,
is he,
he's not a household name.
BC level household name.
I guess.
I don't lie.
I don't like,
I don't like B c and d very much,
but uh,
it is gross.
I apologize.
But that movie moon that he did was fucking sensational.
That was really good.
He's really,
he's,
he's really a really good,
accurate,
but,
but you know,
sometimes enough of the chameleon that that makes it hard for not only the
public to track him,
but also,
you know,
for him to be cast and stuff.
You know,
it's like,
Oh,
who's that guy?
You know,
cause he's,
he's always so good and so different.
He was so good in that movie moon because it was,
that was a really subtle role and it was a role where the entire movie was
basically,
I don't want to say I should stop myself right there.
I don't want to say what the entire week,
go watch it.
I want to give you a spoiler.
Yeah.
But he,
uh,
I can't even say what he does in the movie,
but very,
very interesting moving,
very intense and interesting movie.
And,
uh,
she shows his range from that to the iron man character that he does.
Brian,
look,
go to my Twitter and,
uh,
there's a thing that I retweeted earlier today from,
Dan Carlin hardcore history guy.
He,
uh,
put up a trailer of a Gingiss Khan and the Mongols from like the John Wayne era.
They did a movie [inaudible] con.
It's so bad.
Oh my God.
It's brilliant.
It's a,
if you go to my Twitter is the third one down.
You got it.
Look at this.
Crank this up so you could hear this way too.
You hear John Wayne as Gaviscon.
First of all getting is kind of was fucking Chinese.
All right.
Yeah.
Look at this forever counselor.
Right?
The car.
That's the great con.
John Wayne.
Listen to him is getting
his con slaves.
You have this,
it looks so fake.
I,
but otherwise me.
Listen to me.
There are moments for wisdom,
Gym Yoga.
Then I listened to you and there are moments for action.
Then I listened to my blood.
I feel less tired or a woman is from me.
He sounds the same.
Like is he doesn't every other movie
taking you for a wipe board.
Ty and I take your dowry tomorrow at Heart Gut.
I make gift of it.
Dwayne con,
he doesn't believe he's saying Dwayne con city.
I keep of all my balls.
Oh,
hug me shall be this dry
treachery.
People are so dumb.
Back then he was that big of a bad ass.
Awesome.
You know?
But somebody made a new trailer forward.
Is that what this is?
Yeah.
They didn't have trailers back then,
did they?
They did,
but they weren't this,
whoever did this is a bad motherfucker.
I don't think they said that.
The day and date on them like that.
It almost makes me want to go wash this.
You know what?
Maybe we can get a resurgence from this movie,
but playing this and then it could be like the rocky horror picture show of,
of,
of barbaric dramas.
Everybody could go to it and quote the words that John Wayne says as Ganga is
con,
do you think,
do you really think that they,
they let him do that voice because he was that big of a bad ass.
They thought if he was to be like,
aw,
y'all and stuff like that,
they would,
it's always funny in any movies where it's like a,
you know,
English or American actors playing for in a foreign roles.
Is that,
uh,
you know,
why,
why would you have a,
uh,
an accent,
but speaking English,
you know,
so they just go,
they just say fuck it.
And they just have him,
you know,
not having actual accent and speaking English.
It's like Tom Cruise and Valkyrie,
Kevin Costner and Robin Hood,
Prince of Thieves.
Sometimes they're just like,
hey,
he's a big star.
Fuck it.
He'll just talking his voice.
He'll just talk how he talks.
I'd rather him do that then actually try to fake it,
you know?
Yeah.
I just don't,
I don't,
I wouldn't see the point y'all,
the only thing maybe you should do is let you know,
say it in the actual language and then they have subtitles,
but that's like,
you know,
there's only so many actors that could pull that shit off.
Like I was watching a movie called,
what was it called,
French kiss
French something.
It was Kevin Kline and Meg Ryan.
But Kevin Kline was French in it and he speaks French a lot in it,
you know,
and uh,
he clearly just knows French,
but it was still,
I was impressed.
I watched a sneakers last night.
Again,
I haven't seen that in forever.
Does that hold up such a good movie still?
Yeah.
I highly recommend,
highly recommend watching that.
It's Robert Redford,
Dan Akroyd.
Uh,
that one dude from a,
there's like a team of five and they're all like hackers.
Yeah.
Such a good movie.
I'll tell you who it was all in it right now.
The fifth state movies coming out.
Speaking of hackers,
I,
you know,
that guy really looks and sounds like Julian Assange,
but I hear the movie as a kind of muddled,
like they don't do a good job telling the story.
Robert Redford,
Dan Akroyd a river Phoenix.
That's what's it called again?
Sneakers.
Such a good movie.
I watched it last about hackers,
right?
Where the other two,
I think it was like 15,
Sydney Portiere da Da da.
You fucking barbarian.
You don't know.
He was like the first like super acceptable black guy or a girl in a team or an
or a super nerd.
He talked like a European,
right?
Yeah.
He was pretty a fancy,
super elegant,
super eloquent.
Uh,
Joe or like,
if you think back like the old days,
like the sixties and seventies,
who is the most elegant black guy?
They called me Mr Tibbs.
Cindy pulled.
Yeah.
He was very,
uh,
always annunciated.
Yeah.
And that's how they,
you know,
the east,
uh,
you know,
the,
all the white folks,
they kind of ease them in with like,
guess who's coming to dinner.
Got like a whole movie about a white family that doesn't like a black dude
coming to dinner.
Exact Donal.
Who?
Mary MacDonald.
Oh yeah,
that's her name.
So maybe she didn't go on the mission though or whatever.
Don't they go on like a don't they have to get in somewhere and Sydney 40,
there's a van they ride around in a van a little bit accepting an honorary
Oscar.
Denzel Washington brings up Sydney port ea.
So that was,
that was probably in the last year or two,
right.
Um,
since 2008 the five years,
it says the 74th annual Academy Awards.
That's sane.
There's been 74 academy awards.
Isn't it funny how much they loved Patty chest?
Does that sound like you were trying to interrupt Joe?
You should save that as a drop.
One of those corny morning zoos do,
do,
do.
Um,
what the fuck was I saying something about how the Academy Awards,
who goes about them?
How,
why has there been so many?
It's just amazing how much back patting their is that they have these gigantic
elegant award shows for essentially entertainment.
You know what I mean?
It's really cool that you do this.
It's really cool that you provide us with his awesome entertainment.
But the amount of fanfare that goes into that,
like here's a perfect example.
The guy who,
the,
the guys who were working on the,
the Higgs Boston trying to find the God particle,
they're,
they're getting a Nobel prize,
you know,
and who,
who fucking knows that?
I mean,
everybody knows when the academy awards are out,
everybody knows that there's a red carpet and the lights are going off.
That the scientists,
if,
uh,
these guys who won the Nobel prize physics,
three
of them,
the,
if these guys were walking down the street,
no one gives a flying.
Fuck,
no,
no one's gonna take photos of them.
They might be more responsible for changing the way we perceive the universe in
any scientist who ever existed.
And they could just walk freely down the street and no one gives a shit.
But if you know there's a red carpet and some person who was in the awesome
pretender of stars and nothing wrong with them being an awesome pretender,
but as they walk through,
I mean it's really weird.
We're weird.
Weird is finding a full people to mostly the winners are often very attractive.
Not these winters,
these Oscars.
No,
the other ones,
the Nobel prize.
That's why more people look at the Oscars is the attractive to look at of these
doctors need that date,
like a low hand or something like that.
It's the symmetry of the face.
Symmetry guarantee you.
There's probably some pimp ass man,
like man scientists out there that's looking to get himself a movie star wife
like that might be like a good move.
Like a Neil degrasse Tyson type character.
He could nail himself like if he wasn't married,
I don't know if he knows,
but if he wasn't,
let's just an alternative universe,
the very least he could get like a Padma Lakshmi who?
That girl that's married to a Saulman rusty.
I don't know who she is,
but you know who he is?
Yes.
Yeah,
she had actually,
he had to go into hiding for a while because of this say tannic versus and a and
she's just a host of top chef.
Oh really?
And she's gorgeous.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
And that's,
so she's married too.
Cause like that's your point was that there's,
there's,
you know,
these hot chicks out there that are really,
really,
really smart dude with a lot of notoriety for being smart could actually scooped
him up.
Yeah.
It makes a girl look like a bad ass bitch.
She's hanging some movie stars hanging around some superstar astrophysicist guy
who's creating fucking laser beams and shit.
Did you see the rail gun that day developed?
Uh,
Holy Shit.
You want to see the next level of warfare weapons?
There's a fucking thing that I developed that it shoots through this solid wall
of steel punches a hole through and go straight in a straight line after that
seven kilometers.
Wow.
Yeah.
Who pull this up,
rail gun invented.
Watch this demo.
This is going to make you shit your pants.
Is it recently?
Because there's the one from 2007.
Oh,
it's recent.
Here.
Let me find it.
Real gun invented.
It's,
it's incredible.
I mean it really is like,
and they show up.
They have a village of it's shooting through a wall.
Will they showed they started it with bricks.
Um,
they were,
they were shooting bricks.
Like they would just load up a brick and fucking punch through this fucking
thing.
I'm not going to feel safe in here now.
And then they,
um,
and then they decided at general atomics rail gun test 2013 but Google that they
develop this alloy bullet that's this giant metal piece that's aerodynamic and
it breaks off sort of like a stage rocket,
I guess.
They shoot it,
parts break off.
And then there's the aerodynamic end of it,
which is like a little,
a speaker,
like a little like,
it's like a giant bullet is what it looks like.
And it just punches right through this fucking steel wall.
Check this shit out.
It's like the other parts of this pill,
it so fast that when they jettison it does,
you don't walk five blocks six and after they tell that's a brick,
not that impressive.
So we came with the kit.
We basically came with an aerodynamic ground and that that's the next round of
testing that we did.
We did that this summer.
This was around,
it was actually developed by bowling,
what they'd done to support this program.
What do you see here is the armature that use to generate the force and the,
and the round.
So with that there's a,
there's a,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of pounds pushing around down the bore.
And then once it gets out the Bor,
then uh,
air hits the Sibo and causes the suburb to separate.
And then this was the round that we launched down range.
And,
um,
we launched this particular round at 1600 meters a second,
which is about mach five and it with no gun elevation meetings,
zero degrees elevation.
Uh,
this thing went seven kilometers down range before it stopped and that's after
punching through a steel plate about an eighth inch thick,
a hundred yards down range.
But look at how it just keeps going after going through that steel plate in
eight inch thick
different options
and it goes through it like it doesn't even exist
say in the navy,
look like it slowed it down and go seven kilometers past that Oh nutty.
Or people were like,
when it's not good enough at killing people yet we're missing something.
Do you think that guy in that video gets laid a lot?
He's in key shows.
Girls that video,
I think when the camera was up waste above,
it's cause someone was talking this deck that he would think he demands that it
demands that at all times where he sends a rail gun through your fucking house
thing,
looked when he wants,
he pulled all the parts off.
It looked like a dick dude.
That thing looked like death.
That's,
it was a death dick.
It's incredible that we were not satisfied with our ability to blow shit up.
Like we're constantly inventing new and terrifying ways to shoot through walls.
I want to see a villain get killed by that thing in a bond movie.
Did you see the video of the Serbian rebels getting hit with a missile?
Uh,
no.
Well it's not,
not super gory but it's got to be brutal.
Insanely shocking.
This guy's in a window and he's looking out the window and there's these guys in
a truck and they're driving the truck up the street and the truck has like armor
man on it.
It has guns on it and these guys are standing in the middle of the street and
the guy drives a truck off.
And I guess when he was driving the truck off,
the missile was already common as the people that were standing where the truck
were.
All of a sudden you see them like go fuck and try to run.
They get like a couple of steps and this fucking thing hits the ground and it's
a huge ball of fire.
This insane explosion.
Everything goes flying by and then you hear like,
oh blah blah blah,
hello,
walk blah.
You know,
that's like what?
They'll say God is great,
God is great when the shit goes wrong,
they were like,
it's like holy fuck.
That's like God Damn Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ.
And so you look out the window and it's just fucking shoot crater.
This fucking gigantic missile just slammed down the middle of the street and you
get a sense of how fast it would hit you.
Like when you're on the ground,
you don't know it's common.
And then these guys just looked up to like shit and it was too late.
Well launching,
no thing.
Yeah,
we're,
we're really good at blowing people up.
I say we as in you and I,
Joe,
did you see that picture that somebody sent me and you on Twitter of his
emotional needs?
Pit Bull that he brings on planes.
Oh,
come on.
No Way.
Yeah.
Look at this guy brings you the emotional needs pit bull on planes.
That is so crazy.
That's so crazy.
Ivan tipples.
Wow.
Well you know what?
It's nice that your dogs nice and you love them today they're making here in Los
Angeles.
So they're making it a law.
I think a or they're voting on the law,
but I think it's gonna pass a that you have to get your pitbull spayed and
neutered,
uh,
after the age of four months.
Oh yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
because I guess we're just,
there's so many pit bulls here that they're just killing like piles of them a
day,
you know,
at the pounds and stuff.
That's crazy though,
that you can force someone to get their,
their dog spayed.
Like what if you're breeding dogs?
What if you were responsible dog breeder that breeds dogs and just saying,
you know,
they get a special license or some probably get wondering license.
I think just this probably just for private ownership of a pimple.
Yeah,
maybe.
It's interesting because it changes the personality of the dog.
You know,
have you mailed dogs?
It makes them a more sedate and make some,
they get there,
they're tired or they lose like a lot of their energy.
Enthusiasm.
I noticed a big difference when my dog got got fixed.
It's like older dudes on,
you know that have low t.
Exactly.
I mean certainly it's probably a calmer dog,
but um,
my veterinarian that I went to for years before he passed away,
never believed in Spang male dogs.
He didn't believe in having them breed and create puppies.
You know,
you don't take care of.
It's like,
you know,
you're with your dog all the time.
If you're a responsible dog owner,
you know that your dog's not going to breed.
He's like that sad like unless you dog as a real aggressive problem,
you don't need to spam.
And then,
but then other people have said,
yes you do because otherwise your dog can get testicular cancer.
And my take on that has always been like,
okay,
so they can't get testicular cancer if you cut off their testicles.
Like,
is that your,
are you really,
is that really what's going on here?
Like,
why is it,
why are the dogs getting cancer?
Their balls?
Like is there a way to avoid that?
Just check for lumps on the dog's balls once a week.
That's already doing stuff around there.
Anyway,
so excited.
He's so excited.
Oh No.
We've even discussed about this on the podcast.
Why?
This is a concerted effort on my part to eliminate why does your dog run away
from you every Wednesday?
Oh No,
no,
not Wednesday.
But I can understand the girl thing now getting girls spade because you don't
want them to have periods all over the place.
Well,
it's also that,
you know,
they,
they go into heat and then that attracts dogs.
And I,
when I had a dog that lived next door to a dog that was in heat,
it was because
I thought there was something wrong with him.
He was in pain.
He was like going down the stairs and Yiping and pains.
I thought he'd like broken a hip or something like that.
I thought he was in pain because he was injured.
So I brought him to the hospital and,
uh,
the veterinarian was checking him out.
And this is like a,
is there a dog in your,
uh,
your neighborhood that's in heat?
And I said,
I don't know why he goes,
because your dog's just horny as hell.
And I was like,
are you serious?
Like my dogs,
so horny.
He's crying so bad.
He was,
you know,
this big,
strong dog.
But he would walk in,
come him panic and I'd be like,
it's okay buddy.
It's okay.
What's the matter and sound like my poor dog,
I carried him to the car cause I thought it was broken.
Meanwhile I was just horny.
That's,
yeah,
that's the noise I make.
You know,
if a girl comes back to my place,
it doesn't put out.
Sorry.
Danson sexist.
Use the term,
put out.
How dare you give it up.
Oh my God.
He said give it up.
Give up the honey hole.
Oh God,
you were hurting.
Give it up.
Is that a thing?
Um,
I'm sure it's a thing people call it that for sure.
Honey Pot,
I think they call it.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Honeypot and honey hole,
you'd be better off with a hole in a pot.
Seems like a whole,
you can be a little bit more specific about the size of it
and call it a big old hole.
You don't want to put your Dick in anything you're calling a pot that's can't be
big.
Like what's,
even if my child's pots did they play in?
They're still fucking quick,
quite big.
You know,
a cauldron my back in the day they had cauldrons.
Yeah,
you,
that's what Chuck Jack Two giants would fuck.
Have you been paying attention to this fucking government shutdown?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
I don't enjoy paying attention to it cause it just makes me angry.
But I,
I do check in every day to see what they're saying about it.
Yeah.
I am so confused.
It's a big whole mass.
It's just stupid.
I'm so confused.
It's exactly what's wrong with American politics.
I'm also,
I'm just,
I'm so confused that they let it get to this point too.
I don't understand.
I mean,
how could they fucking,
like if it's really is like a standoff thing where one side won't won't,
it's like one third.
It's not even a side as much as it's like a third.
I don't understand crazy.
I don't know how it ever even gets made.
I don't know how it's possible.
Everyone's just like a,
you know,
everyone wants to be reelected is that is their number one goal.
Uh,
you know,
and if they're about to retire,
their number one goal is to take down then the number one person on the opposing
team and that seems all they want to do.
Yeah.
Just,
I just have a hard time believing that,
you know,
in this day and age that we can allow the whole system,
did you shut down for more than a week because they can't agree on something?
It seems like,
I understand.
I'm not trying to be naive that they have to represent their constituents and
that they have viewpoints
on certain things like Obamacare.
But apparently that's the big stipulation.
It's all about the,
the,
the program that's going to be instituted for healthcare,
mandatory healthcare.
There's certain stipulations about the program.
I know that a lot of business owners don't like,
but I know that other people think it's good.
Another thing,
people think that it's a great step.
So I don't,
I need to fucking really dig into it and,
and take an evening and really research it from a bunch of different points of
view.
Because right now I'm getting,
you know,
just sort of abstract information about it and I don't,
I don't have enough to talk about it.
It seems to me that it's a very divisive issue.
I try not to talk about these things just cause I,
you know,
I don't consider myself an expert,
but I do pay attention.
You know,
I do listen to all of it to try to understand it.
Um,
and in the case of this,
it just really feels like,
uh,
if Obamacare is fully implemented,
then that's,
then they no longer have the Obamacare is going to ruin the country argument
unless it really does ruin the country.
And in which case,
why won't they just let it happen if they think it's going to ruin the country
and then they can jump in and be the saviors,
you know?
Yeah,
I guess so.
There seems like they're trying to stop it.
Just any kind of success that can be had by the current administration needs to
be stopped at any cost.
It feels like what's going on.
And also laws that are put in place are much more difficult to resend.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Obama,
Obamacare is a fucking law.
Yeah.
You know,
so they're,
they're going to all this trouble to fight it when there's all these other
issues that's,
that genuinely need,
like,
why aren't they all just trying to create jobs?
Like why is this the discussion?
Do you guys understand the Obamacare at all?
Like,
like if,
if,
is that because Kevin Pereira just signed up for it?
Like that night at midnight,
he was on the computer.
It's signing up for Obamacare and I think he pays like $200 a month or $300 a
month for like really fucking awesome insurance because of it now.
But,
uh,
it doesn't start until January.
I guess you have to sign your first.
It's,
this is the sign up period.
They're trying to get everybody,
but like there's all these ads on TV telling you that it's bad and that you
shouldn't sign up for it.
They have ads that try to encourage young people to not sign up for it because
they have,
uh,
a young woman is sitting in like a gynecologist office with her feet in the
stirrups and then the gynecologist has a giant ugly,
uh,
Uncle Sam,
a paper machine,
Uncle Sam head that rises up and,
and it's like looming over her vagina.
Like trying to tell young people,
don't sign up for Obamacare because then they're there.
Then the government's going to tell you what you can do with your vagina.
What was that true?
It was the government has a vagina agenda.
Well,
the thing is,
is they argue that Republicans do are,
are,
you know,
do have a vagina agenda,
but it's not too,
it's so weird that they've,
they basically have just flipped the script.
Like it's supposed to be that,
you know,
uh,
the Republicans are anti woman,
but they're trying to make it look like Obama's really the one that wants
to tell you when,
what you could do with your vagina.
So it's just a manipulative,
it's about healthcare period.
So they use it to like sexual health care.
They go to that right away.
Babies,
Vagina.
Your wife's purse.
Yeah.
Well cause that's what the Democrats had been using.
They've been saying the Republicans are anti woman,
so this,
so they're just using the same approach but saying,
but putting it on Obamacare and Obamacare is anti woman.
It's really fascinating that they're allowed to do that.
It's really fascinated.
They're allowed to editorialize at all and that they're allowed to have like any
sort of dramatic influence at all and their commercials.
It's so crazy.
Like you're allowing people to manipulate.
You know,
Doug Benson has shown time and time again.
He doesn't care about the people of Los Angeles.
Doug Benson promotes smoking marijuana for underage children,
including your children.
Doug Benson is not a good American.
In fact,
he would live in Canada if it wasn't so fucking cold.
Doug pence and we'll make up shit presidents.
They almost can say that man,
they can,
they're so dramatic.
It's not facts like very clear,
simple vetted facts that had been verified in both sides and agreed to,
no,
no nonsense,
hyperbole,
drama,
dramatic writing,
fucking manipulation,
the truth,
all that standard fare and oh,
by the way,
we've been paid for by giant corporations.
All of this manipulation,
the changing of the opinion of the culture there,
that sheep beloved,
the culture has been all manipulated by giant corporations under the law hall.
All totally squeaky clean in legal and encouraged and necessary for the
political process.
Doug Benson,
why the political process needs money injected into it.
There's very few laws that are against rich people.
Very few rich feeling get away with almost anything as long as they can.
Not Rape or murder rich people are set.
Yeah,
they're never going to jail.
Jerry's a lot.
Well,
unless they rip off rich people,
unless you've already made on then I mean like there's nobody's in jail from the
last,
uh,
you know,
crisis on Wall Street and nobody got arrested for that.
Well,
Bernie made off.
You can't really connect to the crisis on Wall Street,
but,
no,
but I'm just saying went down because he ripped off.
It's super hard.
But if you think about it,
there's the super rich people,
there's people that lost money,
but there's also people that have gained money in the craziness of the market as
it existed before.
And there's people that recognize that a correction was going to be in place.
And it's also people to recognize that because of the political money that they
put into the system,
the banks were rescued.
So even though they lost all this money and it could have been a catastrophic
failure,
the catastrophic failure for these companies like this,
listen,
we're going to be taken care of.
And so then the government gangs money from the people perhaps back up the bank
saying,
listen,
this economy is very fragile.
We have to keep it going as only we know how.
So we're going to need some money.
We're to need some money and we're sorry about this and don't worry about it.
We're never going to happen again.
Um,
your tax dollars would never go to these.
Why is he getting a bonus?
Oh,
he needs a bonus,
man.
He gotta get his bonus.
If you don't get his bonus,
man,
he'll leave.
He'll go somewhere else.
He did the job.
Fucking bonuses.
Bonuses were half a million dollars.
That was the limitation.
The cap cover.
We've been informed that people are upset about the bonuses we need to raise the
debt ceiling.
Yeah.
We have limited their bonuses to $500,000.
That's so much money for the average person to get a $500,000 bonus in the mail.
They'd be like,
holy fucking shit.
Can you imagine if you go to your mailbox,
you've ever,
you just received a bonus from work.
What are the fuck they say?
You're just not thinking about what kind of car?
My mind,
I'm going to buy a fucking new corvette.
Goddammit.
You can say,
how much is the down payment?
A house?
How much am I going to have left?
You would just start going over the money in your head.
That's what their bonus was.
This is after they're already making millions in their bank fail,
Duh,
crashed into the fucking ground and was prop backup I taxpayers in a way that I
completely don't understand,
but if you talked to Brian Cowen,
he will Fox News you to death on this.
Oh really?
Well,
you know they paid the loan back within nine months
where that money go then come on.
They need to pay more.
Everyone needs to pay for it.
Figured this out.
Work this fucking thing out.
This thing's a mess.
This is a fucking housemate and a sticks and and gluten gum all fucking patched
together and fucking wavering in the wind joke.
Please tell me you saw that Yoko Ono on David Letterman.
I refuse to watch it.
Why?
She makes my blood boil.
God,
she makes my blood boil and I don't want to be a mean person,
so I don't want to say mean things about her.
But I this,
this idea that what she's doing is some sort of,
I guess it is a performance art.
If we're talking about it,
it elicits a response from you.
But the response is not the kind of response that I want from my 30 seconds to a
minute of watching something.
It's the,
it's a response that makes me annoyed.
I love,
what does she do on there?
That,
so I love the first comment or the most,
uh,
voted comment,
you know,
on Youtube,
the one at the top was,
it says,
what the Goddamn fucking fuck did.
I just was like,
almost 200,000.
All right.
Cause she came out and did a song or something.
Let's put,
let's play like 90.
Yeah.
Well she,
um,
when she got John Lennon soul into her body,
she got a double life.
David Letterman hanging in.
Good Guy,
but he's the only having her on just for the,
this sort of attention
a lineup has changed over the years.
But whose namesake has remained at the helm and their new album right here is
entitled to take me to the weird intro.
Oh my goodness.
What a trip.
That would be
least.
What'd he say?
Take me to the what?
Hell,
aiming lips.
Yoko Ono
in the house,
I think.
What's the name of her album?
I don't know.
You were talking to,
fuck.
I can't look it up.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I changed my tune 100% I love her now.
I thought this.
I thought it was going to be terrible.
I mean it's,
I don't enjoy it.
Well,
your third fight,
it's not.
She's mixed with the flaming lips,
so yeah,
the 90% of it is bad ass.
Yeah.
You know what I'm in.
It's fine to have her screeching of the flaming lips or plan.
Yeah.
It's got a good beat.
They're bad ass.
Flaming lips are dope.
They're making her sound awesome.
If you is the backup singer,
he's like,
Ooh,
I like this.
Do you like the hooded figure with the a cocktail shaker?
Yeah.
You know what I love about this?
This bitch could do this all day with different songs.
She hasn't written a word of this.
This is all noise coming out of her mouth.
So yeah,
just take your daughter's singing to the mirror and playing dress up.
I Dunno man.
She seems pretty good at this.
This is a new style.
She looks good to suck a dick.
You know what?
This would be good man.
That's how she got John.
She had to do something to hook that motherfucker.
He was so into her.
She must have a super pussy.
He must have Gudu Pussy.
No other way.
Is that her boyfriend on the floor?
No,
it's Robert Plant who gave up,
I guess he uh,
and he took the hood off.
The beautiful thing is you could do this all day with her.
Like if the flaming lips had her singing songs,
they could actually be pretty fucking good song.
Like that would be a good album.
I'm not bullshitting you because I like music that doesn't have songs that
doesn't have lyrics sometimes.
Like I listened to foreign artists because I don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
I enjoy it.
Of course this would get tired.
I couldn't listen to it every day they have a broad spectrum of what I like
Brian [inaudible] for instance.
What are you think I was listening?
You want to way over here?
Somebody screaming while dying loop tipped over.
I don't know.
Jay Z?
No,
that was listening to what?
Dwight Yoakam.
Oh,
I like a little country music every now and then,
I guess.
I guess he's a good actor.
I guess at the end.
David.
David says,
Son who's in sling blade,
right?
[inaudible] David King.
He was scary.
Yeah.
Well she's tiny.
I mean,
he's big,
but she's telling me
I am crazy.
Hello.
It's fun when you
leave the theater humming the music from the show,
isn't it?
I love it.
Just love it.
But it was a friendly burn.
Yes.
She has no idea.
She's royalty.
You have to be friendly to
her even if she drives you crazy even.
But if she hot,
like if bill burr and her were in a room together and you saw that bill burr
bit,
have you seen that bill Baer bet.
I can imagine.
It's a video that he,
uh,
from his Monday morning podcast,
this podcast is one of the most unique podcast because it's just him talking
into a microphone,
which just goes off,
which I've done before.
I did back in the early days.
I did a few of those like that where I would like read Twitter and like,
I,
there's a couple of things I was just going to talk about.
It just wanted me being baked,
rambling.
But bill does it every week and it's really funny and some,
one of the best ones,
if you Google it,
um,
bill burr,
just Google bill burr Yoko Ono and John and Yoko are singing with Chuck Berry on
stage and build does like some fucking most hilarious commentary on her and him,
that whole situation between John and Yoko that I've ever heard.
It was fucking,
and with the video,
like whoever made the video because it wasn't bill,
it's a fan,
maybe video and splice it together perfectly and edited it perfectly so that
like,
as he's talking,
you see the look on Chuck Berry's face when he's fucking realizing that Yoko
screaming into the microphone.
Yeah,
Ya Ya,
Ya.
Cause Bill burr did the rent and then they made the video to match the rant.
Yes.
Fantastic.
Oh that's one of the most beautiful things about the internet is these fan
created things.
He's fabricated videos.
I was at a film festival a couple of weeks ago and I just tweeted on my thing,
I wonder,
I want to know someone make a picture of what it would look like if James Woods
had Elijah Wood's eyes and within two minutes,
three people at Photoshop,
his eyes onto James Woods and every picture was creepy as fuck.
I'm sure I've done it.
Started getting even worse.
And then someone started photoshopping his dick.
Cause James Woods has a notoriously big deck.
Oh does he?
Can you get those on Twitter?
Can you see a lot of shows different Twain's I guess why he's so how he's been
so cocky,
very cocky.
He's,
it's supposed to have a monster hog.
Are you allowed to have naked stuff on Twitter?
How's that work?
Yeah,
you are.
Because a lot of the strip girls of the super crazy point pictures like if you
go to a porn star,
that's what I'm saying.
Page.
How's that work?
Is pictures of them with Dixon and and stuff.
Did they have to be locked?
Like you have to approve?
Just let it looks pretty,
pretty open range.
I think maybe like,
you know,
Twitter could shut him down.
Well that's when some of the things that people like about Instagram is that you
can lock it.
You could have your own thing.
We only your friends can get into to check it out.
You have to approve them if they don't get it.
That's crepey.
Wow,
that's weird.
He looks like a robot.
Yeah.
James Woods with Elijah was eyes.
Um,
how did we get to talking about James Woods?
I just brought it up as an example of we know about how you can,
uh,
you were talking about how people should cut together.
Like that's what I've been thinking about.
You also,
you know how we talked about how you should do commentary on street fights and
stuff.
Yeah.
Another thing you could do though that would be awesome is just take classic
fight scenes from movies
and do Joe Rogan,
uh,
you know,
commentary through them as if it's,
you guys,
if you're calling a fight,
but it's as no one ever done that before.
I don't think so.
Like,
like a movie,
like they live that really long fight scene and they live be so much fun.
If you just recorded the audio of you talking over it and just set that out and
then people just get that and then they rent the movie and watch it and then
listen,
just sync it up.
So they listened to you talking about it while they're watching it.
Hmm.
That might work.
Be Super Fun
money.
You'd have to like get the rights to the movies and shit like that to do that.
You can't just do that.
No,
they just do it.
Really?
Yeah.
Like Pete,
Pete Holmes and Adam Carolla.
They'll watch a movie and do it and just have a discussion while they're
watching it do that.
As long as you're not recording the movie and using the soundtrack of the movie.
I talked to this about you about two years ago.
I said talk to you that we should do this.
And you were,
you were against it at the time.
No,
no.
Well I think cause you were,
cause you were referring to in terms of my Benson movie interruption,
like why don't you film it or why don't you release it?
And the reason for that is because I can't record a lot.
I like the live audience element.
I like improvising while watching the movie and the live audience element.
So you can't,
there's no way to record the audience without recording the soundtrack of the
movie that's in the same theater.
And that's,
so that's,
I just think it's fun as a live event,
but what I'm talking about here is,
is,
is totally doable.
It's just not,
it's not something I want to do necessarily.
Right.
Yeah.
Or just to you or you could call it a comedy album.
You know,
just like,
uh,
you know,
Joe talks through some of the greatest fight scenes and maybe you put a bunch of
them out there.
Seems like you'd have to pay them.
It seems like,
especially if you are profiting off of it,
you would have to pay them.
Well,
for some reason Corolla gets away with it.
They just,
they just,
uh,
you know,
it's sort of like they're just talking about the movie.
So,
you know,
as long as you're not playing the actual movie,
I'll find out.
You know,
it's like if you wrote a book on it had a lot of quotes from a movie,
I don't know.
I don't think you'd have to pay anybody as long as you're saying what movie it's
from or we could play the movie and have Joe do it like on an ice house
chronicles,
I don't get it.
Why would that be like,
do it live
still?
I think the person who's doing it,
you can see you're still,
you're opening yourself up because then it could be possibly,
yeah.
Would that if he does the icehouse chronicles and,
uh,
the people who listened to that also live listen to his show.
So it's basically like his show,
you know,
there's an argument for that to take down notice.
Yeah.
Is that what happens is just give you a take down that trial.
But see the thing is,
man,
it's depends on how the laws get changed.
It depends on who's coming in next.
It depends on if Republicans are going to be an office with another going to
tighten down on this kind of shit,
whether or not they're going to promote lawsuits like this.
You know what,
they're going to make legal and what's not legal because he's,
you know,
people can sue if they think that they're going to get paid,
they're going to sue.
That's suing is a way of generating.
You might get paid just so that you don't have to pay more.
Yeah.
Sometimes people paying,
I know people that have been sued for things that they never did and they had to
pay because they didn't want to deal with any more legal
trauma takes time away from them and so they had to give up like 25 grand or 30
grand for nothing.
Like,
I know a guy who was in an argument with someone and the guy claimed that he hit
him,
he didn't do anything and want to be giving them money just to shut him up.
You know?
And once you do that,
that's the problem is,
you know then if,
what if he has friends and he tells everybody,
Hey,
you know I fucking,
I go to this guy into a,
an argument and then I said to you,
hit me and I made money off of them.
Like there's creepy fucks out there that just try to manipulate the legal
system,
make cash.
I'm just going to stay inside from now on.
Do it Doug,
do it.
Don't be a pussy and no wheat.
Don't be gumming up your fucking insides.
Patent lawyers are kind of like that.
Sure.
A patent lawyers,
patent trolls.
Patton Oswalt.
Yeah,
those,
those assholes that we're going after podcasts called patent the troll.
No,
I love that guy.
How dare you see coming day,
but words,
I don't know.
He's hard to nail down these days as he fell.
I spray popular works a lot.
Do you watch justified?
No,
he was on a,
like a recurring character on the last season was died.
He,
it's a great show.
It's,
you know,
Elmore Leonard.
So it's really like,
you know,
tough.
And so it's based on an anemometer novel novel based on his writings.
And he wrote a lot of the episodes he passed away recently,
but uh,
he,
he was early involved in the show and it's,
uh,
it's,
I love it.
It's one of my favorite shows on TV.
What's his most famous Lamo?
Probably because of the movie was the most popular movie based on,
was not probably get shorty.
Yes.
Did you ever read that?
No,
I've never really read any of his books,
but the plenty of things that have been adapted from his books,
especially the ones that he has a finger on a hand in like are really good.
Like he,
you know,
his books I imagine are like screenplays,
and have just lots of clever dialogue and interesting situations and characters.
Yeah.
We were going over the other day how many different movies,
Stephen King books had been turned into.
Oh,
I can't wait to Sydney.
Did you come?
Did you find a number?
It looks crazy.
Number of Stephen King,
but he wasn't in the pot,
wasn't on the podcast.
We must be at least 50.
Yeah,
there's be in that range.
There's a lot.
Plus there's a bunch of mini series for TV included.
The shining wangle ears.
It remember it Salem's lot.
Salem's lot.
Yeah.
A lot of a man.
Uh,
he might be the baddest motherfucker
grove all time when it comes to fiction.
I mean he really might be,
when you stop and think about how good some of his movies were thinner or how
good some of his books where he had some great fucking fiction books.
Really Fun.
The shining is a fucking fantastic book.
Yeah.
Well that was great.
That was the funny thing.
When the shining,
the movie came out,
it lovers of the book were really mad about it.
And then the shining kind of had to take on this life of its own and become
like,
it's like a separate classic,
you know,
cause it's a classic movie and the book is classic,
but they,
they really,
you know,
there's not,
they don't have a lot in common other than a family staying at a hotel over the
winter,
you know,
the transformation was and was
much more,
um,
much more slow in the book.
The transformation of Jack Too.
Jack Street
crazy looks crazy when they're driving up to the place where he's going to do
his first interview.
He's already like,
hey,
this is great
honey.
I just need to do my work and everything.
Fine.
There's a,
there's a lot of great uh,
conspiracy.
There's a movie called room two 37,
and it's all like shining the movie scholars and Kubrick scholars or you know,
at least so called they call themselves that.
But they,
um,
it's a whole movie of just talking at length about what all the hidden messages
in the shining,
you know,
cause like,
cause you know,
people like to say that Stanley Kubrick is the one who directed the fake fake
moon landing.
And in the,
in the shining little Danny wears a sweater that has a rocket ship on it that
says USA on it.
So everybody has jumped to the conclusion that he really did fake the moon
landing a footage and this was his fun way of a poking,
admitting,
admitting to it.
Well,
there's,
as opposed to he's making fun of the fact that people,
uh,
you know,
said that he faked the moon landing,
which it could be,
or it could just be,
it's a cute kid in a cute sweater that happens to have a rocket ship on it.
There was a bunch of parallels.
Apparently it wasn't just that one.
Oh yeah,
no,
there's a ton of stuff,
but it's gets so deep and so ridiculous like patterns in the carpeting and like
also throughout the movie when they're moving around from room to room in the
hotel,
like where they're going in from scene to scene doesn't match up.
So sometimes if they go down a hallway that's just a long hallway,
sometimes they head off in the same direction and it just in a kitchen,
you know,
like it's the,
the,
the um,
uh,
architecture,
you know,
the way the whole place is laid out is a,
doesn't make sense.
But that you could say that probably in a lot of movies because just the way
movies are shot,
you know,
like we'll use one side of the room for one season,
then we'll pretend the other side of the room somewhere else or whatever.
So it gets so deep.
But it's called room two 37.
And also you never see any of the people talking about these theories though.
The entire movie is just clips from the shining and then clips from other movies
that kind of reenact the things he's,
uh,
they're describing.
Yeah.
There's another one that I watched,
um,
by a guy named Jay Wiener.
It's called Kubrick's Odyssey,
a secrets hidden in the films of Stanley Kubrick,
part one Kubrick and Apollo.
And it's all about those connections with the Apollo Moon landings and Kubrick's
films.
And he even has,
uh,
some sort of a claim that the method that Kubrick used was the same method that
he used on 2001,
something called front screen projection,
some,
some type of,
something along those lines.
And uh,
he,
uh,
claims that they used it to a film,
certain scenes and the moon landings that he can prove it.
This guy was a,
he's a a,
these guys that go like way out like that I can have like,
and there was a 230 stairs at Jack walked up and he moved over to room two,
three,
six,
which is exactly the distance between the earth and the moon and hundreds of
thousands of miles.
And you're like,
oh yeah,
they come up with some really good ones.
Like there's a poster for ski skiing,
you know,
like a advertising skiing on the wall.
But they say that the skier and the shape of it looks like a minute tar and uh,
and then they're like,
and they also say,
you know,
and why would there be a poster for skiing if the resort is closed every winter
because there's too much snow there and they don't,
the visitors can't get in and out.
So it's like,
yeah,
but they just,
Stanley Kubrick just put a dumb poster on the wall,
you know,
like it's that,
an art director on the set,
you know anybody on the set just put that poster there cause it was a ugly blank
wall or something.
Exactly.
It's like they think they think way too hard about every little choice that the
distance between the earth and the moon varies and moves around a little bit to
stay at two,
three,
six.
Oh there it goes farther and I'm pretty sure the distance between the earth and
the moon varies.
Let's look at that distance.
Did you,
are you going to see that carry remake?
Yeah,
he was just saying that he looks great.
To me.
That's a little bit,
it's sacrilege.
It doesn't editing the original one,
you know,
girls carry,
no,
it's going to be more straight forward than the original.
The original is such a unique movie.
It's got so many weird Depalma isms in it and um,
and this new one's just going to be,
I think it's just going to be as straight forward telling of the,
you know,
the exact same story.
Oh,
so it's just the same movie.
Yeah.
But without,
you know,
without diplomas,
wacky,
you know,
the marketing for it is fucking awesome.
You see that video that they,
a viral video that they release that's going out right now.
It's crazy.
When they took a coffee shop and they set it up with,
uh,
they pretty much built the whole thing and they had like this track running up
the side of this wall so this guy can get thrown up and like pushed up and like
they have a remote control tables.
And so what they did is they did all this shit and they wouldn't,
when people are coming in to get coffee,
uh,
they just started fucking with people.
This was Carrie did this,
the movie Carrie.
Yeah.
That's so smart and it's really good.
Like this is probably one of the best pranks.
And why?
Like those are all actors around here.
I'm sorry.
No,
she's an actress.
There's coffee inside of my computer.
Just get away from me.
I would have felt the set with more of those real freaking out
automatically.
I would start laughing.
He started laughing.
Yeah.
I'd be like,
oh,
okay.
When thing that he flies on,
it's got a big line on it.
See,
I wouldn't have him down five more of those because right now it just looks like
he's on a track.
You know,
it looks like one of those carnival things you hit and then we tried to ring the
bell.
Right.
That's how you feel Brian.
But that guy,
it would be crazy.
I like the way they tables all spread out.
It's like the scariest part actually
that one to recording and she's like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Some of the record.
Anything these days,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's an interesting book.
Um,
the book is amazing and it was the big hit for,
for Stephen King.
The book was the book that got him out of poverty.
And uh,
it's interesting because he had thrown it out.
He had written some and throwing it out and he decided like,
he didn't know what it was like to go to the prom.
He didn't know whether or not the girls would do that.
And the guy would go to the prom with her.
He didn't understand the emotions behind it,
like coming from as a woman.
And so he was gonna toss it and then his wife pulled it out a trash,
like he was out of the house and she started reading it and then she said,
stick with this.
Wow,
that's good.
That's where that my good wife,
that's what that book,
and I know his first wife,
we still wear this first one.
The distance varies from the earth to the moon by 43,592 kilometers.
So yeah,
it varies a lot.
43,000 kilometers.
That's like 20 something thousand miles.
It's a lot of fucking miles dog.
Yeah.
So it does.
Stephen King hasn't had as many adaptations,
is that thousand kilometers and whatnot.
What's Brian Doing?
Hundreds of both.
So that that number two,
three six or two three seven the distance of the earth.
The moon.
What?
Oh yeah.
What are you doing?
That's 26,700 miles.
Boom.
There we go.
Thanks.
What is it like a one mile I think is 2.2 or 2.2 kilometers is one mile.
So a hundred kilometers.
Just 62 miles an hour I think.
I think that goes cause they do that with zero to sixties with European cars.
You know when they tell you the performance numbers they did.
They break it down to kilometers and kilometers per hour per second.
The Oh they're too much for you Doug Benson.
They blow a fuse.
I think his seven bottles.
I'm still thinking about,
I'm thinking about the new version of carry and how I don't,
you don't want it?
I don't,
I hate,
I hate being against it to be honest with you cause I like the idea of it,
but it's just like,
to me it's just going to be,
I guess I should look at it like a play where you like the play and then you,
you can see more than like I've seen who's afraid of Virginia Woolf a couple of
times with different castes and it's like different people emerge as the
strongest characters and you know that you see different things in the writing
because of different performances.
But it just seems like Julianne Moore and that girl Chloe marets or just sort of
forced to kind of go through the motions of being like the two people in the
first movie.
I mean as it was so big,
she's just a religious zealot is yelling at her all the time and eventually the
daughter starts getting some cutlery out and making it fly across the room.
And yeah,
it's kind of different than like King Kong when they redo King Kong,
they have to have the Fay Wray character and that's the original Carrie depalma
had tons of like split screens and like,
uh,
you know,
lots of a wacky stuff that he used to do all the time.
And it's,
so it's got a really unique,
and then sissy spaces,
this girl in the new one is like,
she's an outcast.
She's gorgeous.
Like she's a cute girl and like,
you know,
how messed up is she that she,
uh,
I assume she has the same incident in the beginning of the movie where she gets
her period in front of everybody.
They don't have,
they don't have a sissy space,
like type actresses anymore.
I mean,
what actress?
That's what I,
that's what somebody said to me.
They're like,
do you think Sissy space?
It's ugly.
And I said,
no,
she's not ugly.
But she's ugly enough that when in these early scenes it's believable.
And then when she's at the Prom,
she actually looks pretty greatest American hero.
Remember that?
Yeah.
William Katt,
that guy was the first guy that I've ever met.
Uh,
that was famous when I was in la.
He was in front of me at Starbucks and,
you know,
gut was he nice?
Like wow,
I shouldn't say meet me at my first one.
Your first sighting.
My first sighting.
Yeah.
See,
look at they go to the split screens.
Right.
I forgot about the split screen shit.
And it was a look at that crazy hose.
People getting into host.
I don't know if that's going to happen in this new one back then it was weird
fucking movie man.
Weird movie.
No,
he made it really kind of artsy fartsy movie out of a lot of just basically
yeah.
Straight forward a book,
you know.
Um,
wow.
I forgot Travolta was in it.
Yeah.
It was a good fucking movie man.
And especially for the time time it was a,
or as a big hit and it's like,
and it's a reference point,
you know,
like don't take care to the prom,
like pig's blood being dumped on you.
Like,
people make references to it to,
you know,
to this day,
even though the original movie doesn't yeah.
It doesn't get a lot of play.
No,
that's true.
Yeah.
When you're talking about a girl going crazy and psycho,
she goes,
she'll go care and you don't go Carrie.
Yeah.
And uh,
the book's incredible though.
It's really good.
Yeah.
I was,
I was super into Stephen King.
I wrote a letter to Stephen King about how much I didn't like Kubrick's the
shining and he wrote back,
typed on a postcard.
Like he would just sit and type back letters to fans and he wrote back and you
still have that a very,
yeah,
he wrote a very diplomatic response,
which is just like,
you know,
I don't,
I don't control what happens to my books when they're made into movies,
but he was,
it was well known that at the time that came out,
he thought he hated it.
Like he was angry about it.
Well that's why they did that remake where they did it on television.
They did it much truer to the book.
Yeah.
And then still not a very good movie just because of other choices that were
made.
Like the kid that got to play the kid was an annoying kid,
actor,
you know,
and,
and so he wasn't engaging central character.
Did you like the guy from wings?
Stephen Weber.
Yeah,
he was all right,
I guess.
But I just didn't,
I,
I haven't liked to single made for TV.
Stephen King from beginning to end.
There's parts that are good.
Like it,
like the pennywise looked cool.
It was really scary looking,
but I thought the movie was too silly.
Well,
it's also the,
you're trying to make a movie out of a book,
but instead you're making like this mini series thing.
Yeah.
Which takes many,
many hours to why get out.
And a lot of times they lose the,
the,
the dynamic energy of a movie.
You know,
if you're sitting and watching a movie,
movies have beginnings,
middles and ends and you're,
you take them all in one chunk books,
you let it sort of unravel in your day.
You know,
you'd read when you can,
you come back to it,
you get right back into it and it's fine.
People usually don't watch movies,
movies,
one chapter at a time.
Yeah.
So when you're watching an hour a week or an hour a day for three days or
whatever,
however the fuck they did it where they had it as a mini series,
it just doesn't work that,
yeah.
Like I didn't think the standard mini series was terribly good.
I didn't see that.
Who was in that?
Um,
I think the main guy was played by a Jamey Sheridan.
Don't show this because I want to see that movie.
I don't want,
I hate watch trailers are the worse these days.
Like if I'm really excited about moving,
I'll just not,
but you're just avoid the trigger.
Right.
The reason I was watching it because I'm so in love with that,
that girl in that movie,
she's just beautiful chick.
So I don't buy that at all.
The plainness and like,
yeah.
I mean they have to change it to that.
Everybody hates her because she's better than all of them.
That's so stupid.
That's what I was going to say about,
uh,
when somebody said,
you don't think Sissy spakes it's basics beautiful.
It's like,
well no,
she's not ugly.
But she also was not on a cosmopolitan teen when Keri came out.
She was an actress who was chosen because she could,
could seem like a religious nut outcast.
Yeah.
She's very pale.
Her eyebrows or this girl girl now is the girl of the moment.
So they're just,
well she's got to play Carrie cause she's,
you know,
we want,
we only want to bet on horses that are going to win and she's,
she's a good actress that people like.
But the problem is I don't think that works,
you know?
I mean,
I'm not saying that she can't pull it off and maybe she does it awesome.
But I don't think people go to see movies because of the fucking stars in it.
You know?
I don't think people want to see avatar because that Australian dude,
nobody knows who that guy is.
Oh absolutely know that he works.
But they went to see avatar because it was avatar because it was a bad ass
movie.
Stars can push something over the hump,
you know,
like,
like the heat we were talking about earlier.
If that wasn't Sandra Bullock and Melissa McCarthy,
it could,
it could easily just not be a thing.
Right.
So if it sucks,
it's okay.
Well,
big name actor,
that's what you're saying.
Well,
I'm just saying that they,
the unfortunate system needs insurance policies all the time.
So they only want to work with the people that have already made a lot of money,
but all those people were in a surprise hit at some point and that's why they
are now bankable stars.
You know,
like when they hired Sandra Bullock for speed,
they,
you know,
that was probably,
they were just looking for a young actress who could,
you know,
fill the role.
Cause I already had a star in Keanu Reeves and then she busted out.
And it's been a huge thing ever since he just counted the chemistry that they
had,
the chemistry that they shared.
Um,
she's,
I mean,
I thought she was adorable and speed and I saw these and waiting for her to make
a good movie until gravity.
It finally happened.
So these images of Kiana Reeves,
poor guys apparently gained weight and so like
people are taking photos of him.
I can't go Keanu Reeves fat.
No,
I just don't.
A couple of weeks ago he looks great.
Maybe there's a fake FAP key and a got this movie man of Tai Chi that he
directed where he also,
he also plays the villain in it.
Oh,
it's a fake guy.
fake fat.
Keanu fake look like the fat and old on suicide.
Watch calories get fat to it.
So is it him or not?
Whoa.
Well hmm.
This is weird.
Canneries is 48 do's loud to get punchy has been alleged,
which it looks like he's happily doing.
Judging from these photos at Cannes.
Maybe he had his shirt off and he's a little listen to this show.
No,
he doesn't have a shirt off.
Fuck.
That's for a role or something.
There's no way he looked like that.
It can work in May of this year.
No Way.
Someone is in love with Kiana raise.
We just,
how did you buddy Google Keanu Reeves at fantastic fest.
He was there in front of me doing a Q and a and that's not what he looked like.
So you think it's Photoshop?
It's either or.
He played a fat guy in something and people got pictures of it.
At what fest?
I remember the time Matthew mcconaughey went nuts on the beach with some palm
fronds and was running around and it was on TMZ and stuff that he was whacked
out of.
His mind went around on the beach.
That was,
he was shooting a film and that was a scene in the film where he did that and
people just put it out there like,
or they did it at my other great example is when I'm see,
look at him.
Okay,
so how long ago is this?
A month ago or two weeks ago.
Maybe.
He just went gangster in the last two weeks and got fat as fuck.
Yeah,
it looks thin and healthy.
That's great.
Yeah.
So that doesn't make any sense.
So what does that other one is that,
is that right?
Maybe that's not even him.
I think that's not what it might be.
A guy that looks like him.
That's fan.
Yeah,
I'm looking at it.
Let's look at it against
yeah cause it really is.
It really does look like it looks I just got fat for a couple of months.
Yeah but that's hard to do to chop off that weight that quick.
There's a lot of weight like his neck.
I mean there's a lot of fighting in his movies and cocaine.
He looks different though.
Like his nose looks bigger in the fat one.
Is that cause his nose got fat I tickets.
He was either acting as a fat guy.
Hmm.
Cause you saw the pictures of mcconaughey is the aids dude.
Right?
Well that was when he decided to lose a shitload of weight.
But it's insane.
It's like life threatening.
How might how Theni got well you should never do that.
Those guys who do that for roles,
they're crazy.
I know a,
what's his face?
Batman.
The fuck's his name?
Christian Bale.
Bale machinist.
The machinist.
It was incredible.
That might be one of the scariest transformations I've ever seen a person make
ever.
Cause he was on death's door,
like pull,
pull images over that prime.
Or if they have a video of Christian Bale in the machinist.
I've never,
I mean I think a big deal when rob Deniro Lecan Hayes is just as bad I think.
Oh I don't think so.
It's pretty bad is it really?
I thought this guy was
the worst I've ever seen.
Mcconaughey.
Hey,
he looks like a ball.
Like I like his neck is so thin.
Then his head's kind of normal.
Makani sizes.
So weird.
Do you remember when Robert De Niro did it for regent bully gained all that
weight to play Jake Lamata as an older man and everybody was like,
this is incredible.
How did he do that?
Look at that.
See if you can find video of it though.
God Damn.
Because the video was even more terrifying because he see him walking around and
you're like,
Jesus Christ.
Like that's like Jack Skellington.
Well that's really him.
That really is Batman.
Yeah.
Well he doesn't remember that guys name and I watched him bail.
He's super transformative.
That guy.
He was amazing in the fighter.
Yes.
And he's got,
it looks like he's got a crazy haircut and this new one American hustle,
he's got the weird seventies comb over thing.
Yes,
yes.
He was great in the fighter.
He played,
I'm Micky ward's cousin,
a Dicky Eklund,
the famous boxer from Boston.
Sanely aggravating personality like that.
Movies really,
it's great,
but it's also like,
you know,
almost every scene he is,
he's in,
it's just an awkward,
horrible,
Catherine was a crack head and he was on that HBO series about a crack.
And Lynn,
you know Lynn,
Massachusetts are,
uh,
it was it Lynn Lowell,
Lowell,
Massachusetts was a,
an area was really bad.
Like crack hit Lowell,
super bad.
And the eighties this is the video of him in the machinist.
So you see him where he's walking around like it's how many days in a row he
hasn't slept.
It's like,
and then to go to all that trouble for something that's not even a particularly
good movie.
Well,
I think he tried to make it good,
but sure.
You know,
how the fuck can you even tell what's going on around you when you're that
skinny?
Yeah.
I mean,
that dude literally died.
He got down to about a few days.
I have
no food from death.
Yeah.
I think Chris was that Laurence Fishburne?
Did he eat all of his food?
How dare you?
Christian Bale gained 109 pounds for Batman begins after losing 63 pounds for
the machinists.
Bill went from 121 pounds to 230 pounds in six months.
Oh my God.
He was 121 pounds and he did this movie.
Yeah,
that's insane.
So by the time the filming began,
Christian Bale had dropped 190 pounds.
Oh my God dropped.
Oh,
you mean back and forth or no,
he had been moved 190 pounds.
He had to drop 290 pounds.
Right.
He had dropped to 190 pounds.
I'm sorry,
a hundred what?
It says,
you're probably heard that Christian bale came to 109 pounds for Batman begins,
meaning get buffed up for Batman begins after losing 63 pounds for it in the
Michigan machinists.
So yeah,
it's a swing of 190 from his lowest to his house.
To his full Batman late.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense because that would mean that he's like 300 fucking
pounds.
He was never that big.
He was a,
well one one 93 is like two 50 yeah.
He wouldn't be that much.
He's not that bad.
Yeah.
I don't get that.
That doesn't make any sense.
Stop reading that source,
whatever that is.
That doesn't seem to make sense.
Yeah.
Can you pull up a scary movie?
Matthew mcconaughey?
It's the movie's called Dallas something.
There's not magic Mike.
No.
I told this story before,
but I saw it.
Oh,
this reminds me.
I saw that movie with my mother,
Magic Mike in San Diego that time we were in San Diego for comicon and I just
saw the first cut of the movie.
We were making chronic con and both of you guys are really funny in it.
Wheeling.
Yeah.
Remember when we were in the green room and the guy that runs the club said,
hey,
can you meet one of the investors?
And you're like,
okay,
this guy comes in and he's holding like he at one point he's holding a bottle of
champagne and then he just lets it go and it drops on the floor and crashes
everywhere and then you're standing right next to him in the movie going,
yeah,
normally when you let go of a bottle like that,
it just floats in the year.
But there was lots of good stuff.
Cause Brian Brian was hitting on some girls out on the street in San Diego late
at night and you were like,
you did this whole rant about,
uh,
when they're barefoot,
they're at their most vulnerable because if they,
yeah.
And also because if they're willing to walk around in glass and Piss and
everything that's on the ground,
they're like,
you know,
there's no rules anymore.
You show these girls,
you see girls,
but their faces are blurred.
But there's one that looks like she's taking a shit in the middle of the street
and that's what gets Brian's attention.
He's like,
oh,
I'll go talk to her.
And then you start talking about girls holding their shoes.
They're vulnerable.
There was so much wrong girl comicon or people got so drunk downtown San Diego,
it's like that every week.
What is the deal with San Diego?
Why is it so wild?
It's just sixth street.
It's just that one street.
It's like,
same thing with theirs.
Sixth Street in Austin or you know,
everywhere has got a street or a neighborhood where there's just so many bars in
one spot.
It's also you can walk around.
Yeah.
It's the,
it's the,
you know,
the,
uh,
the herds of people moving around and then getting too drunk and then next thing
you know,
fists are being thrown.
Yeah.
I've seen that more in that area anywhere else.
So real world,
the MTV show,
when they have the kids in downtown San Diego and in downtown Austin and a few
other places,
s the,
everybody's so drunk and there's camera's following these kids around and the
show hasn't started airing yet.
So somebody's going to get jealous and angry that these people are on TV and
start throwing fists there.
There people on the real world to get arrested in the San Diego and Austin
additions like there were kind of regular arrests of cast members because they
get too drunk and get in trouble on those in those,
uh,
party neighborhoods.
I can imagine it.
I don't,
you know,
you can,
whenever you get people drinking together in big groups,
you're going to see a fight.
You're going to something and know Austin version.
There was this one kid who like got hit in the face like by a guy
like,
you know,
he couldn't even see a common,
the guy just,
and the guy's face is blurred.
I think they eventually found him and,
and,
and try to him.
But like on the TV show,
it looks like he just,
some guy got away with it cause he didn't stick around to sign a release,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
But those girls in the chronic con will be blurred and it's also not,
the movie's not going to come out for awhile.
He just showed a picture of you found it.
Yeah.
Look at that.
That's nothing.
Wait,
wait.
Oh,
that's not,
no,
that's not as bad as Christian Bale.
And then it shows him in the how to lose a guy in 10 days.
That's just,
TMZ is greatest hits of Matana.
Hey Ryan.
Kelly do it.
Do not give Brian counts.
Started on Matthew mcconaughey because he will go into this whole rant about
acting and being authentic and like he gets like,
he's not a muck a fan,
so he gets,
he's been killing it lately though.
Democrat Makonnen Hazen been,
I love it.
Very versatile lately.
Super strong opinions on actors.
It's like,
okay,
yeah,
that's really going on here.
It gets,
yeah,
it kept me of those parts would have,
you'd like to have done.
Yeah.
When one person says I like so and so,
and that movie,
Oh,
she was terrible in that.
Okay,
well we both just said a bunch of words.
Let's go find something to really do.
Well,
it's also,
Brian does a lot of acting,
so he liked judges activity.
You can see.
I looked at act,
I look at acting completely as an outsider,
so I see like even if I don't like the type of movie he's in,
he's definitely can act like,
how could you say that guy can't act?
Did you see contact?
He's fucking great in that movie.
He's in great note of that.
What was that movie where he played like a killer killer Joe?
Was that what it's called?
That movies intense with a chicken wing.
Do you see that?
There was a couple movies like that.
There was another one where he did a freaking move and killer Joe where he's
like,
he's a hired killer,
but he,
he does this thing.
Did Gina Gershon with the chicken wing that's really grabbed,
when was this pretty recently?
I saw it three and a half stars at South by southwest last year.
Oh,
it's a 2011 movie.
It's a recent movie.
Oh,
I haven't seen that.
No,
you should check it out.
It's really crazy.
You can,
you know,
you can get it onto iTunes or some shit like that out tonight.
There was a,
um,
there was another movie though.
What's it called?
Stricken or something like that?
Matthew mcconahey.
Serial killer.
What's,
there was one in the past where he played some really fucking,
how do you spell his name?
That's a tough one kid.
Yeah.
That's a tough one.
Kind of.
Hey,
serial killer.
Serial killing Rocana.
Hey.
Yeah.
What handsome pastor it is.
Alright,
let's say frailty.
Yeah.
Frill.
Okay.
2001 that was crazy man.
Bill packs then.
And I don't,
I haven't seen it long.
It's got seven to 7.2 out of 10 on rotten tomatoes.
Have you heard of the movie Bernie?
Bernie?
What's that?
It's Jack Black Plays Bernie and mcconaughey.
Pele's
like a local,
a police detective.
How you spell it?
Br.
Bernie Ibr and I,
and it,
but it takes place in Austin and it's based on a true story.
So the movie is filled with people that were really involved in the story and
knew the real guy,
uh,
as themselves.
Yeah,
it's cool.
And it's really,
it's really well done.
It's Richard Linklater.
That guy did dazed and confused.
Doug Benson come with a strong recommendations.
I got like two movies to watch now.
Killer.
They're both really interesting.
But you know,
they may not be here a,
you know,
a cup of tea.
But I like a lot of different kinds of tea.
Yeah,
no I know that about you for sure.
That you like.
Uh,
whenever I see you raving about a movie and I always find it interesting cause I
know you don't,
you don't see a lot of them.
And then also don't probably love a lot of them once you do.
So when you rave about something,
it's very,
very passionate.
I heard you on Kevin and being and talking shit about Riddick they were talking
about me seeing really,
it was so bad.
I,
yeah,
I didn't even see the whole thing.
I just saw a section of it.
No,
I know.
This is just not for me.
But I enjoyed pitch black.
I thought pitch black.
It was really cool.
That's what I immediately said to Kevin and being as I defended the,
that it was that that movie wasn't bad and it was good.
And then the chronic chronicles or read it Riddick was ridiculous.
And then then the last one,
it was like they trying to go back to pitch black,
but now they've kind of stuck because they've got the budget of a bigger movie.
So they couldn't,
they didn't really force themselves to be a terribly inventive.
It's weird how much he's alone so much.
Like this year is the weirdest year in that Tom Cruise Will Smith Jr uh,
that guy and there's a fork.
Oh.
And then of course Sandra Bullock,
like all these movies were a big stars are just sort of like a low alone in a
space or in a futuristic planet.
And they've all,
you know,
until gravity,
they've all just failed.
They're all doing terribly.
It's like one of these,
they're the star Egos.
Like I don't,
there doesn't need to be anybody else in this movie.
But that's different because at least in those,
in all these movies that have come out,
whether it's a Tom cruise movie or the Will Smith movie,
it's some dystopian future.
Yeah.
This is more current event and,
and the reality of space junk,
you know,
entering into,
I think gravity came from a better,
I don't think Sandra Bullock was like,
I need a star vehicle where it's just me,
but,
and you know,
and I don't think Tom Hanks did that about Captain Phillips,
but it's still,
it's an interesting ego thing that any actor thinks that they're them alone is
worth people to just watch an entire movie.
Well,
that's the other movie we talked about earlier.
Um,
Sam,
what's his face?
Yeah,
Moon Moon,
Sam.
But that movie was done from a,
you know,
a real place of artistry,
and it was such a interesting premise.
Yes.
Yeah.
That wasn't interesting.
It wasn't like,
you know,
him just saw just,
it's not show off he,
or trying to be a move.
You know,
the script came before the actor.
I'm sure Tom Cruise a developed oblivion.
Like it'll just be me running around on this planet.
He did.
I'm sure he did.
Yeah.
You know,
he's,
uh,
I think that guy works
really,
really hard.
Like I admire how hard he works to make the silly movies that we get to see.
It was a little volcano twice a year.
No,
sure.
I'm pretty sure.
Is there,
is there somebody that you would,
is there a dude you would left?
Fuck,
you could just cause you admire him so much.
Not Anymore.
What happened
once?
Shame on you.
Yeah.
I just don't,
yeah,
I just don't think I would just be like,
can't we just get some drinks?
I have a smoke mad flavors in a Twitter war right now.
We'll do,
do you know a guy named Phil?
He prints?
No.
Philly prince one on,
uh,
Twitter.
He's a former odds maker.
Had,
I don't know,
Espn Hoes.
Fox radio host.
What's he getting mad at?
Joyful.
I don't know,
but it's,
it's whole page is just going off on him like,
well maybe so the guy like you will mention it.
Yeah.
Good one.
Uh,
yeah,
he's like going off on him.
His thing like he got fucked in the ass and prison and doing all this back to
this guy.
If Joey wants to talk about it.
I have Joey talk about it.
Don't give any guy like that any kind of attention when something like that
comes up.
That's someone who's trolling and what they're trying to do is they're trying to
get attention from guys.
Got a lot of attention.
And what'd you do?
He just gave him a dungeon.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It's hard to,
I mean,
in this case,
Brian could have not done that,
but,
and sometimes it's like when it's at you,
especially,
you know,
when someone says something really mean or stupid to me,
like sometimes I'll retweet it or something.
Yeah.
And because I just,
I get a real charge out of the horrible things at all that some of my fans will
then say to that person,
you know?
And it's fun to see that all the people defending me.
But at the same time,
you know,
people write to me and say,
you shouldn't feed the trolls.
You know,
you shouldn't,
you're just giving them the attention they want.
It's like,
yeah.
But,
uh,
you know,
I think ignoring it sometimes makes them go on to seek more of,
more of that attention.
You know,
this was not even,
yeah,
but this doesn't even have to do with us,
but it's like he wants to talk about it.
Let Joey talk about it.
But if I want to talk to me,
Yo,
you want to talk about how great he is.
But it was funny earlier when you met,
when we were talking about having the pit bull on the,
on the plane is it's like you were kind of shrugged your shoulders like,
well I guess you know,
the guy really likes his dog or whatever and my feeling is I would hate to sit
next to them,
but it's such a lottery that went away.
When are we going to sit next to him?
So let the guy have his dog,
you know,
like we're not going to have to put up with it.
Yeah,
but that's one guy.
The problem is other people see that and they want to do it.
There's a reason why you can't have dogs on plants.
One of them was a,
people are fucking allergic dogs.
Some people are deathly allergic to dogs.
Some people,
their eyes swell up shot.
Second of all,
it's not sanitary.
Your dog's got a why open ass.
There's no diaper on it.
It's not clean.
They fought like crazy.
They don't give a shit whether or not people right next to them.
If they have to pee,
what are you going to do?
It's stupid.
It's a dumb thing.
If you're going to travel with your fucking dog,
a dog should be in the luggage compartment like everybody else's dog.
That's how it's supposed to be.
But if you're on with somebody that does have their dog,
cause it's happened,
right?
Yeah.
I've been next to people that had a dog to say all that to them or do you just
go love dogs?
You just go,
I'm never going to have to sit next to this person again.
So what difference does it make?
Yes.
But no,
in the current,
the current climate,
you don't,
you know,
most likely you're not going to have to deal with that.
But doesn't it make you feel like Larry David though,
when you see something like that and like on his show,
he would consistently call people out on stuff and it would just lead to these
horrible arguments and these horrible interactions.
Like,
don't you feel like,
you know,
you just can't police everything.
She can't police everything.
But I was at the fucking bookstore and this lady,
I love headache,
a giant dog.
It's like a fucking great Dane and I'm,
I'm reading a magazine and I feel a dog's nose touch my hand.
And I looked over and there was a fucking great Dane and I go,
whoa.
And she goes,
don't worry,
he's friendly.
And I go,
why is he here?
And she goes,
he's a service dog.
I go service dog,
or what does he servicing?
I go,
what are you doing?
Like,
you know,
I'm at a fucking bookstore is a 180 pound dog jogs enormous.
And it's licking my hand.
Like this lady Ivy,
she's not in control of it.
And I love dogs,
but that's not cool.
You should have a fucking animal in.
You can't totally control inside a bookstore.
It's what she say to the service question.
She didn't answer me.
Yeah cause there is no answer.
She went and filed the paperwork and got it.
Anyway,
even we've already discussed this on the podcast.
Adenoids osmium unfortunately anybody can get one emotional support dogs.
They're trying to change that law,
that trying to change it because people are abused the shit out of it.
Yeah.
It's weird man.
People are fucking weird.
It's weird that anybody would think that that's okay to do.
This is a lady that goes to my restaurant,
a restaurant that I go to a near my house and she brings her dog in all the
time.
It's a famous lady movie star.
She comes in with his fucking dog and this dog has this wide open ass just
sitting there rubbing on the ground where people drop their forks and you know,
drop your cell phone,
pick it up,
get dog shit on your hand.
Even if it's microscopic amounts.
It's disgusting.
It's stupid fucking thing.
It's farting in there and he's licking its own dick.
It's ridiculous.
The I the idea that you should be allowed to bring your fucking dog into a
restaurant.
It's Shit's ridiculous.
Unless you're alone by yourself and your belong mind.
Fuck you.
All right.
Come in because it's an emotional support dog.
That's nonsense.
That's a good one.
That's really,
uh,
that's figuring out a way to rig the system.
[inaudible] hack the American disabilities act.
That's what they did.
They cut into the fucking,
the,
the laws that are in place to help people and they realize that there's a little
loophole here and we could fucking bring our dogs everywhere now.
Twats yeah,
they bring their poop hole through the loophole.
Fucking twats anything good to say before we end?
Can negative like that?
Oh yeah,
let's get real positive.
Has it been three hours already?
It's over.
God Damn.
It goes so fast.
It does cause you're awesome.
Is that why you're good at this?
I listened to her shows drag you and I did a long time ago,
man.
I'll just listen to it like it was in the one hundreds.
I was,
uh,
looking for podcasts on my,
I've got to talk to you about something.
Remind me after this is over.
I can't talk about on the air,
but I've got to talk to podcast related.
Remind me.
Um,
so I started listening to,
um,
some just different people's podcasts was just going over the podcast app on my
phone.
And then I found one of you and I and Brian from like fucking three or four
years ago.
It was like three years ago when we were first starting out.
And I was like,
wow,
let me listen to this.
I didn't remember half the shit we were talking about.
We're talking about things in the news.
It were like a big deal that I don't remember him at all.
I don't remember that.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird when you go over old podcasts.
We've done many of these long conversations.
Like if we had to go through and recap what we talked about today,
we probably,
you know,
would only come up.
We've missed some things.
You know what's hilarious when people come up to me and go to,
what was that story that you talking about in the podcast about there's like a
Russian guy and he got in trouble.
I'm like,
shit,
your guest is good as mine.
400 fucking typecast son.
Which,
which part of Russia?
Yeah,
Jesus.
Louise's.
There's also a lot of parts where,
I don't even remember if this person had been a guest on one of the podcasts
that I've done before,
so I go up to them.
I'm like,
Shit,
how do I know this person does this person on the pockets?
I'm like googling the person's name and death squad just to see if they come up.
Sure enough.
Most of the time it's like,
oh yeah,
he's a member of pointless or something.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
we went over that number two,
there's that Dunbar's number.
You can only keep 150 sort of friendships in your head after you get over one 50
you're just like,
it's like there's no room,
there's no hard drive space.
Your hard drive is filled up.
And so you said those are the names you forget.
Even though there are people you like be happy to know their name.
Yeah.
You walk up and you're just like,
I don't have any fucking idea.
What you should do.
Doug Benson is go to Lumosity and learn like a name game you can play.
They have a motherfucking memory enhancement situation type deal where they hook
you up with games and if you use while he tell them that,
uh,
Joe Rogan sent you,
it will benefit the podcast of the allegedly.
They're good.
We like what they do.
I,
I played the games myself.
It's fine.
I think it's important to work your brain and uh,
besides,
uh,
doing podcasts and talking about things and doing standup and writing and things
like that.
I like,
I like to use my brain a bunch of different ways.
I like to play certain games and I think,
uh,
the,
the games they have on Lumosity have a real benefit.
Tell them that uh,
Joe Rogan sent.
Yeah,
you freaks.
Um,
and also thanks to squarespace.com if you use the code word Joe and the number
10 altogether,
one word Joe 10,
you'll save 10% of your first purchase on new accounts.
Uh,
includes monthly and annual plans,
squarespace.com we're also brought to you by on it.com o n n.
I t use the code name Rogan's save 10% off any and all supplements.
Well,
we back at least one more time this week,
possibly twice.
I'm working on some shit son.
I got irons in the fire,
keep it moving.
But uh,
I want to thank everybody that came out to Ontario Improv this past weekend.
I had a god damn fence.
Tastic
fucking shit.
I'm going to be there a October 16th.
Exactly.
I saw they had a promo for Doug Benson.
I'm been,
I told,
I asked them specifically to play.
I don't like the whole clips before shows of other comedians thing.
I just think it's just,
uh,
you know,
there's usually not any real connection there.
Here's another person that tells jokes that you should come pay a lot of money.
You see?
So I'm kind of against that whole thing.
Uh,
but uh,
knowing that you were there last weekend,
I was like made sure that they were playing my clip because I know that,
uh,
you know the Joe Rogan fans are nothing if not dedicated.
They love you dunk bed.
Yeah,
I love,
I love that they come to my shows.
They love Joey Diaz too and Joey Diaz is performing there as soon.
Can't love him.
And for him they're playing the
podcast where it goes off on ranch dressing.
So the whole blue cheese with wings and go fuck your mother.
That rant.
Is that what they play at the beginning when they have,
instead of his stand up,
they just play him going off to do more of that smart.
That's a smart move.
It's a good way lost if I didn't bring it up.
Cause he told me that in private once,
like I heard the original one where we were just like,
like,
like Hooters or something and he's,
he like,
I fucking ran Trenton like,
and he went off and was like,
Holy Shit.
Ranch dressing.
It might've been lies,
but it might've come back again because someone offered him rant again the other
day.
We were hanging out again and some guy offered him ranch.
He would you like ranch with your wings?
Like a joke?
Like he thought it was a joke.
I wonder if it gets that now.
Like people that know who he is.
I'm sure they want to hear the rant in person.
I do not think this particular gentleman was,
he was trolling,
I think he has really just offering them ranch with Wayne.
He's like,
what?
What do you got with your wings?
And the guy was like,
well I can get you some ranch sir.
Like,
he's pretty serious.
He'll fucking ranch.
I want no fucking ranch.
And he's,
he was a very mild about it.
He wasn't rude.
I Hate Asian Pussy.
I say what you hate.
And then they,
people just started giving it to you.
Nevermind Jesus Christ.
I can say that October 31st I'm going to be in San Diego,
uh,
deaf squad Halloween show with Sam Aaa and Tony Hinchcliffe and a bunch of
surprise guests.
Tell the name of the club.
Oh,
American comedy show.com.
I'm going to be there too in November,
I think like the night before thanksgiving.
Beautiful.
Um,
next thing I got to come,
only plugs I'm going to do are ones that are same place that you guys have been.
October 18th.
I'm in Houston at the bar.
You Music Center with a Beautiful Thompson Gora.
Uh,
and then I'll be there in November.
Houston.
How are you feeling?
What are you doing?
Hey,
can you give me that driver's name and Info?
Do you still use the same driver in Houston?
That guy's great.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's it.
It's fucking shows over.
Oh,
November 1st,
second and third of the Irvine Improv.
Um,
I'll be there in December.
I've been doing a lot of clubs lately,
man.
I mean,
uh,
doing like weekends a clubs.
I kind of stopped doing that for a while.
You're playing these days.
They got a lot of these kind of like big clubs that are practically like playing
a theater.
Yeah.
But I really like the size of the Irvine Improv or the Ontario Improv or break.
That shit's perfect.
Yeah,
that's what I'm really enjoying more than anything.
So like doing these shows in of like a tight
group,
like a club,
a real club.
It feels like a club and a theater like in one year.
That's very a very good experience.
The right amount of people.
I like doing both.
I like mixing it up,
but man,
I'm really enjoying the shit out of doing a lot of clubs.
Not Fair.
When people are sitting far away from you,
it's not really a,
you know,
they might as well just be listening to it.
If you can't,
if they can't see you,
you know there's that and it's also you,
you,
you also can't totally hear everything that's going on in the room.
There's a lot of a weirdness when you're in a big room where the people are
laughing.
If you can't keep tagging things,
y'all gotta wait til after it dies down or you can't hear what the guy saying
like I've been though,
I saw Louis Black recently and I realized that while I was in the crowd,
I was like,
oh,
I can't understand what the fuck he's saying.
Like while everyone's laughing hard.
Yeah.
All Right,
folks,
we love the shit out of yet and we'll see you soon.
That's it.
Yeah.
Big Kiss.